Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. We, my dear Crossmen, are Greeks in this American empire. You will find the Americans much as the Greeks found the Romans. Great, big, vulgar, bustling people. More vigorous than we are, but also more idle. With more unspoiled virtues, but also more corrupt. We must run Allied Forces HQ as the Greeks ran the operations of the Emperor Claudius. That was Harold Macmillan talking to the future
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、提前收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我亲爱的克罗斯曼们，我们在这个美利坚帝国里就像是希腊人。你们会发现美国人跟当年希腊人眼中的罗马人差不多。一群高大、粗俗、喧闹的人。比我们更有活力，但也更懒散。有着更纯真的美德，但也更腐败。我们必须像当年希腊人协助克劳狄皇帝处理政务那样去运营盟军总部。这是哈罗德·麦克米伦在二战期间
Labour MP Richard Crossman during the Second World War. And Tom, we do think of ourselves, don't we, a little bit as the Greeks to the Americans, Romans. I mean, people think of us as the brains behind the operation, don't they, ultimately? I mean, I know we're down on our uppers. I know we're not what we were, but I hope we're better than the freed slaves who served the emperor. Yes, quite a few of them must have been eunuchs. They weren't eunuchs, but I mean, nothing to boast about. So we're continuing our World Cup series, aren't we?
对未来的工党议员理查德·克罗斯曼说的话。汤姆，我们确实觉得自己有点像美国人（罗马人）眼中的希腊人，对吧？我的意思是，人们最终还是把我们看作是行动背后的智囊，对吧？我知道我们现在风光不再，我知道我们已经今非昔比了，但我希望我们还是比那些伺候皇帝的获释奴隶要强。是的，他们当中肯定有不少太监。他们倒不是太监，但我的意思是，这也没什么好夸耀的。所以我们要继续我们的世界杯系列节目，对吧？
And we're doing kind of special episodes on the countries that are playing England in the group stages of the Qatar World Cup. So we've already done Iran. And today, England are playing the United States. very salient in the episode we did on iran is that in international relations power balance power imbalances tend to mean that one country i.e the less powerful country is far more obsessed with the other country than the powerful country is with the inferior country of course um so iran is much much more obsessed with britain or england than brit Britain is with Iran, say. Yeah. And we've had that a bit actually, Tom, because we've had that with Argentina, when we talked about the Falklands War many months ago. All those countries that were affected by Britain's empire, either formally or informally, developed a kind of mingled admiration and
我们要为在卡塔尔世界杯小组赛中对阵英格兰的国家制作一些特别节目。所以我们已经讲过了伊朗。而今天，英格兰将对阵美国。我们在伊朗那一集里强调过，在国际关系中，权力平衡、权力失衡往往意味着一个国家，即相对较弱的国家，会比强大的国家更痴迷于另一个国家，而不是反过来。当然，嗯，所以伊朗对英国或英格兰的痴迷程度，要远远超过英国对伊朗的痴迷。是的。其实我们也有过类似的经历，汤姆，因为几个月前我们讨论马岛战争时，对阿根廷也是这样。所有那些受过英国帝国影响的国家，无论是正式还是非正式的，都对英国产生了一种混合着崇拜和
resentment of Britain, didn't they? And I wonder whether that's similar to the relationship that we now have with the United States. Well, what's interesting about Britain's relationship to the United States, and apologies to Scots and Welsh, but we're going to equate England with Britain for the purposes of this podcast. Yeah, shocking behavior, but we're going to do it anyway. What's interesting about it, of course, is that in the 19th century, basically the United States is playing the role of Argentina or Iran to Britain. Britain is interested in the United States, but it's not obsessed by it. Whereas the United States is obsessed by Britain. And in the 20th century, that role reverses.
怨恨的情绪，对吧？我在想，这是否类似于我们现在与美国的关系。好吧，关于英国与美国的关系有趣的是——向苏格兰人和威尔士人道歉，但为了本播客的方便，我们将把英格兰等同于英国。是的，这行为令人震惊，但我们还是要这么做。有趣的是，当然，在19世纪，基本上美国对英国扮演的角色就像阿根廷或伊朗对英国一样。英国对美国感兴趣，但并不痴迷。而美国却对英国着迷。到了20世纪，这个角色就倒过来了。
But having said that, I mean, I think it's not just about power imbalances, because I know that politicians on both sides of the Atlantic hate the phrase special relationship, quite understandably in the context of geopolitics. But I think in the dimension of culture, there is a special relationship for the obvious reason that the culture of the United States does come from Britain predominantly, preeminently, in terms of its kind of beginnings. There are lots of ways on there in which the culture is actually so integrated. Not every way, but if you think about the popularity of British actors even now, you'll see an endless TV, big, big budget TV series in which it'll turn out that half the crew is British or half the cast are British. They're kind of so integrated, aren't they, in some ways, just to be indistinguishable.
话虽如此，我的意思是，这不仅仅是权力失衡的问题，因为我知道大西洋两岸的政客们都讨厌“特殊关系”这个词，在不地缘政治的背景下，这完全可以理解。但我认为在文化维度上，确实存在着一种特殊关系，原因显而易见，那就是美国的文化主要、卓越地源自英国，从它的起源来看。在很多方面，两国的文化实际上已经高度融合了。并非方方面面都是如此，但如果你想想英国演员直到现在依然很受欢迎，你会看到无数的电视剧、大制作的电视剧中，你会发现半个剧组或半个演员阵容都是英国人。从某种程度上讲，它们已经高度融合，甚至难以分辨了。
But that is quite Greek freedmen at the court of Emperor Claudius. Because I think in Hollywood, the British are called white Mexicans. White Mexicans. Is that how people talk about Hugh Laurie? Tom Hiddleston? I believe so. Tom Holland? Tom Holland, Tom!
但这很像是克劳狄皇帝宫廷里的希腊获释奴隶。因为我认为在好莱坞，英国人被称为“白人墨西哥人”。白人墨西哥人。大家是这么形容休·劳瑞的吗？汤姆·希德勒斯顿？我想是的。汤姆·霍兰德？汤姆·霍兰德，汤姆！
Yeah. Is he a white Mexican? I believe that one of the reasons for the salience of British actors in Hollywood is because they're much cheaper to employ than American stars. Oh my word, I can't believe Tom Holland would sell himself so cheaply. I'm not selling it. But what I would say is that the fascination, both for English people and for Americans, about the relationship of Britain and America,
是的。他是白人墨西哥人吗？我相信，英国演员在好莱坞之所以如此突显，原因之一是因为他们比美国明星便宜得多。天哪，我不敢相信汤姆·霍兰德会把自己卖得这么便宜。我不是在卖。但我想说的是，无论是英国人还是美国人，对英美关系的着迷，
is that America, in a way, is taking a path that Britain might have taken, and vice versa. In so many ways, the war of independence is a civil war. Of course. We've talked about this before, particularly in the treason episodes, that at stake in the revolutionary wars are issues that are consciously traced by the revolutionaries back to the 17th century and beyond. So that's why the treason law, Magna Carta, has the salience that it does. Wouldn't you say? I mean, you're the specialist. I would, I would. I would, Tom.
在于美国走上了一条英国可能走过的路，反之亦然。在很多方面，独立战争就是一场内战。当然。我们以前讨论过这个问题，特别是在叛国罪那一集里，革命战争的核心问题是革命者们有意识地追溯到17世纪甚至更早的时期。这就是为什么叛国罪法、《大宪章》具有如此突出的重要性。你觉得呢？我的意思是，你才是专家。我会的，我会的。我会的，汤姆。
We talked in a previous bonus episode for members of our Rest is History club about the historian Louis Hartz, whose works have gone a little bit out of fashion now. I think he was writing about the 1940s, 50s, 60s in America. And he basically argued that the United States
我们在之前为“历史的 rest is history”俱乐部会员录制的加更节目中讨论过历史学家路易斯·哈茨，他的著作现在已经有点过时了。我想他当时写的是20世纪40、50、60年代的美国。他的基本观点是，美国
was a bit of 17th century England that has sort of floated off and been preserved in aspect, that its constitution, its political obsessions, the language of politics, all these things. The religiosity, exactly. They're all kind of early modern England and they've got stuck and not moved on. Well, they have a bit, haven't they? Yeah. I mean, there's a bit of an... When you do hear people arguing about the constitution and what the founding fathers and the framers of the Constitution thought, it is kind of mad to a secular 21st century Britain to see people arguing so vociferously about what people were thinking in the late 18th century.
其实就是17世纪英国的一小部分，它漂洋过海并在某种程度上被完整保留了下来，它的宪法、政治偏好、政治语言，所有这些东西。那种宗教狂热，完全如此。它们基本上都是早期现代英国的产物，结果卡在那里没再往前发展。好吧，它们其实也有所发展，对吧？是的。我的意思是，有那么一点……当你听到人们争论宪法以及国父们和宪法制定者们是怎么想的时，对于一个世俗的21世纪英国人来说，看到人们为18世纪末人们的想法争论得如此激烈，简直有点疯狂。
But Dominic, we're going to do the War of Independence as a 4th of July present, aren't we? To our American listeners. A present to our American listeners. We're very much going to be bringing the British perspective on this. Yeah, they'll love that. They'll absolutely love that, Tom. It's a monstrous display of treason and ingratitude. So that's something to look forward to. But in today's episode, what we're going to do is we have broken down the entire history of England's relationship to America into six key episodes. And five of them are quite elliptical.
但是多米尼克，我们要把独立战争作为7月4日的礼物送给我们的美国听众，对吧？送给美国听众的礼物。我们将从英国的角度来审视这件事。是的，他们会喜欢的。他们绝对会喜欢的，汤姆。这是一场极其无耻的叛国和忘恩负义的表现。所以这很值得期待。但在今天的节目中，我们将把英格兰与美国关系的全过程拆解为六个关键事件。其中有五个非常晦涩。
Let's be honest. They're not the episodes you expect. If you write down now what you think the six episodes will be, if there's anybody who gets them all right. I would be impressed. I would be more than impressed. I would be dumbfounded. But the first episode is an absolute classic.
老实说。它们并不是你预料中的事件。如果你现在写下你认为这六个事件会是什么，如果有人能全部猜对。我会佩服的。我不只是佩服，我会目瞪口呆。但第一集绝对是个经典。
And it's the episode that uh i guess for americans typifies the um hostile relationship between britain and america in the early decades of the existence of the united states and that is the burning in 1814 by british redcoats of the white house great moment in history tom but the thing is that for britain this entire incident is absolutely peripheral it is isn't it it's an annoyance you think most people in britain have even heard of it well great event you see because obviously 1814 1815 as it's the death throes of the napoleonic wars this is the great death struggle that britain has been engaged with revolutionary their napoleoniconic France for decades.
我想这一集对美国人来说，典型地代表了美国建国头几十年里英美之间敌对的关系，那就是1814年英国红衫军火烧白宫。历史上的伟大时刻，汤姆，但问题是，对英国来说，整个事件完全是微不足道的，不是吗？这只是一件烦心事。你觉得英国大多数人听说过这事吗？嗯，这是一件大事，因为很明显，1814年、1815年正值拿破仑战争的最后挣扎，这是英国几十年来一直与革命的拿破仑法国进行的生死之战。
And in 1814, it looks as though Napoleon is finished. As it happens, of course, he's going to make an abortive comeback in 1815, which will be ended at the Battle of Waterloo. But it's continental Europe that is the focus of Britain's attentions. And basically, America is a kind of an annoying blue bottle that's got stuck in the study. It's nothing really more than that. But for Americans, of course, this is an absolutely existential crisis because Britain had, I think, had the British properly turned their attention towards waging this war. I mean, they could have seriously, seriously damaged and perhaps permanently crippled the United States, but they don't. So the backdrop to this is basically, I think, American resentment
而在1814年，拿破仑看起来似乎已经完蛋了。当然，碰巧的是，他在1815年又进行了一次注定失败的复活，最终在滑铁卢战役中彻底结束。但欧洲大陆才是英国关注的焦点。基本上，美国就像是一只讨厌的、被困在书房里的绿头苍蝇。其实也就是这么回事。但对美国人来说，这当然是一场绝对的存在主义危机，因为英国如果——我想，如果英国人真的把注意力转移到这场战争上来的话。我的意思是，他们本可以严重、严重地破坏甚至彻底瘫痪美国，但他们没有。所以这一切的背景基本上是，我认为，美国人对以下事实感到不满：
of the fact that despite their independence, they still feel that they're lying in a British shadow. And I guess the kind of the key grievance is the way that the British who are dependent for their own survival on the Royal Navy. We talked about this in the series we did on the Battle of Trafalgar. The British very cheerfully are impressing American seamen, taking them on board, making them serve on their various ships. And the reason that they feel entitled to do that is that British law defines nationality by birth, and the US allows people to gain nationality by residence. And so it's perfectly possible for the British to see someone as being British by law and the Americans to see him as being
尽管他们已经独立，但他们仍然觉得自己笼罩在英国的阴影之下。我想主要的怨恨在于英国人，他们自己的生存要依赖皇家海军。我们在特拉法尔加海战的系列节目中讨论过这一点。英国人非常高兴地强征美国水手，把他们带到船上，让他们在各种船只上服役。他们觉得这么做理所当然的原因是，英国法律按出生地定义国籍，而美国允许人们通过居留权获得国籍。因此，英国人完全可以根据法律将某人视为英国人，而美国人则可以根据法律将他视为
American by law. And the British obviously are playing by their own rules. So there's a lot of impressment going on. The other thing is that Canada, of course, has remained independent of the United States control. It remains a British possession. And there's the feeling that it's very, very vulnerable. So Thomas Jefferson, who was not, I think it would be fair to say, the British Empire's greatest fan, said of Canada that Providence has placed their Britain's richest and most defenseless possession at our door. And James Madison, who has succeeded Jefferson as president, is absolutely confident that basically that the US is holding a knife to Britain's throat because he sees Canada as being key to the war effort. Its timber supplies the Royal Navy with masts, food from it keeps the West Indies sustained, and also that ships and exports from the United States are vital to the survival of Britain in the war. And so it's in 1812 when it still looks as though Napoleon is preponderant. Yeah.
美国人。而且英国人显然是在按自己的规则行事。所以有大量的强征水手事件发生。另一件事是，加拿大当然仍然脱离了美国的控制。它依然是英国的领地。并且人们觉得它非常、非常脆弱。所以托马斯·杰斐逊——我认为他算不上大英帝国最热心的粉丝——曾这样评价加拿大：“天意把英国最富裕、最无防备的领地放在了我们家门口。”而接替杰斐逊担任总统的詹姆斯·麦迪逊，绝对坚信美国基本上是把刀架在了英国的喉咙上，因为他将加拿大视为战争成败的关键。帝国的木材为皇家海军提供了桅杆，来自那里的粮食维持了西印度群岛的生存，而且来自美国的船只和出口对于英国在战争中的生存也至关重要。因此，在1812年，当拿破仑看起来仍然占优势的时候。是的。
Congress votes in favour of war. Madison signs it into law. And this is both the first declaration of war in the United States history, and it's also the closest vote. So I think that's the measure of the fact that people have reservations about it. So there are good people in the United States. Well, particularly in New England, where there is no enthusiasm for the war at all. And centres of population, so Philadelphia would be the obvious one, where there are lots of Quakers, are likewise basically neutral. So it's not like there's a massive war fever. And I think right from the beginning, there are people in America who think that this is not a sensible thing to have done.
国会投票赞成战争。麦迪逊将其签署为法律。这既是美国历史上第一份宣战声明，也是投票最接近的一次。所以我想这就是人们对它有所保留的证明。所以美国有正直的人。好吧，特别是在新 England（新英格兰），那里对战争完全没有热情。而人口中心，比如费城就是一个明显的例子，那里有许多贵格会教徒，同样基本上保持中立。所以并不存在什么狂热的战争狂热。而且我认为从一开始，美国就有人认为这是一件不明智的事情。
You don't tweak the tale of the British lion, all that kind of thing. So to the British, it's an annoyance. This is very much a secondary theater of war, as we've said. And basically, the war does not go well for America. So their immediate target is Canada. They think, we'll go and grab Canada, but it goes disastrously wrong. The Canadian militia meet the main US invasion force at Detroit, and it surrenders. It's a kind of humiliating defeat. Revenge for Yorktown, perhaps. Right.
你不能去捋英国狮子的胡须，诸如此类。所以对英国人来说，这只是一件烦心事。正如我们所说，这很大程度上只是一个次要的战场。基本上，这场战争对美国来说并不顺利。所以他们的直接目标是加拿大。他们想，我们要去夺取加拿大，但结果却糟透了。加拿大民兵在底特律迎击了美国的主要入侵部队，对方投降了。这是一种羞辱性的失败。也许这是对约克敦的复仇吧。对的。
Very good. Who can say? Yeah. And it's not a total victory for the British. There's a kind of naval war is pursued on the Lawrence River and in the Great Lakes. But it's clear that Canada is not going to be taken. And by 1814, the situation is looking increasingly critical because Napoleon's period in power is coming to an end. The Americans have very clearly aligned themselves with the French. And so the collapse of Napoleon's military position is very bad for the Americans,
很好。谁说得准呢？是的。这也不是英国人的全胜。他们在圣劳伦斯河和五大湖区进行了一场海军战。但很明显，加拿大是拿不下来的。到了1814年，形势看起来越来越危急，因为拿破仑的统治时期即将结束。美国人已经非常明确地与法国人结盟了。因此，拿破仑军事地位的崩溃对美国人来说非常糟糕，
not least because it starts to free up ships and men. And the more ships there are, the tighter the blockade that the British have put America under becomes. Because the continental system that the British have been imposing on Europe, they've also been imposing on America. And so this has also been a kind of a big grievance. And so by 1814, the British have basically decided that they need to bring the Americans to the negotiating table. And the growing numbers of ships and of men that they have means that they can think of a spectacular display of their relative power. Because since 1813, they've got a naval squadron that is based in the Chesapeake Bay. So that's the great estuary that runs between Virginia and Maryland. From this bay, there are all kinds of rivers that snake inwards into mainland US.
尤其是因为它开始解放船只和人员。船只越多，英国对美国实施的封锁就越严密。因为英国人一直对欧洲实施的大陆体系，他们也一直在对美国实施。所以这也是一大怨恨。因此到了1814年，英国人基本上决定，他们需要把美国人拉到谈判桌前。他们拥有越来越多的船只和士兵，这意味着他们可以考虑展示一下自己压倒性的实力。因为自1813年以来，他们有一支海军分舰队驻扎在切萨皮克湾。也就是弗吉尼亚和马里兰之间那个巨大的河口。从这个海湾出发，有各种各样的河流向内陆蜿蜒进入美国本土。
And one of these, of course, is the Potomac, on which sits Washington, the US capital. And so in August 1814, an expedition advances up the Potomac, and it's led by a rear admiral called George Cockburn, or is it Coburn? I'm not sure. And a military officer called Robert Ross, and he has 4,500 troops. And up they go. And the US defences are contemptuously brushed aside. President Madison, oh my God, he scarpers. I mean, it almost gets captured. And the British enter Washington on the evening of the 24th of August, 1814. They enter the White House. Coburn and Ross are able to sit down at a banquet that Madison had left behind in the White House. They consume it.
其中一条当然是波托马克河，美国首都华盛顿就坐落在河畔。因此，在1814年8月，一支远征军沿波托马克河而上，由一位名叫乔治·科伯恩（George Cockburn，也可能是科本，Coburn，我不太确定）的海军少将率领，还有一位名叫罗伯特·罗斯（Robert Ross）的军官，他率领着4500名部队。他们一路向上。美国的防御被轻蔑地扫荡一空。麦迪逊总统，天哪，他逃跑了。我的意思是，他差点就被俘虏了。英国人在1814年8月24日傍晚进入了华盛顿。他们进入了白宫。科伯恩和罗斯得以坐在麦迪逊留在白宫里的宴席前。他们把它吃光了。
And they then burn all the public buildings of the Capitol, including the White House. Tom, this is a great story. Although I think it's an immense tribute to the sagacity and forbearance of the British that they don't burn any private residences. And is there any sort of looting and killing or are they generally quite well behaved? No, they're very well behaved. Coburn was actually quite keen to burn the whole city. He was absolutely gunning for that but ross says no because he says the purpose is not to alienate american opinion
然后他们烧毁了首都所有的公共建筑，包括白宫。汤姆，这是一个伟大的故事。不过我认为这极大地证明了英国人的明智和宽容，因为他们没有烧毁任何私人住宅。这里面有什么掠夺和杀戮吗？还是说他们的纪律总体上相当好？不，他们纪律非常好。科伯恩其实很想烧毁整个城市。他一心想这么干，但罗斯说不行，因为他说他们的目的不是疏远美国的民意，
actually quite the opposite you want to keep people like the quakers and new englanders on side it's to humiliate the u.s government so that they will then be brought to negotiate terms um and that's exactly what happens so the british are in Washington for nine days, then they withdraw, absolute minimal resistance. And Madison promptly sends ambassadors to Britain to negotiate terms. And the British are very, you know, they're very, very happy to basically to agree to a peace treaty. And the US abandons all the war aims with which they'd entered the conflict. But I think they feel that they've been spared. They've got away quite lightly because they've been spared certainly kind of total defeat and very probably dismemberment of the United States. So it's a pretty total defeat.
实际上恰恰相反。你希望把像贵格会教徒和新英格兰人这样的人拉拢到自己这边，目的是羞辱美国政府，从而迫使他们坐下来谈判达成条款，而这正是发生的事情。所以英国人在华盛顿呆了九天，然后撤退了，遇到的抵抗微乎其微。麦迪逊立刻派遣大使去英国谈判条款。英国人非常、非常乐意地同意了一项和平条约。美国放弃了他们参战时的所有战争目标。但我认为他们觉得他们逃过了一劫。他们损失相当轻微，因为他们无疑免于彻底的失败，很可能也免于美国的解体。所以这是一场相当彻底的失败。
Now, this is not how the War of 1812, as it's called, is generally remembered in the United States. Yeah, I was going to say that. It's not remembered that way at all. I mean, in Britain, let's be frank, I think among the general public, I mean, among people who are not history devotees, it is literally just not remembered. Yeah. But in the United States, it's remembered as a sort of great moment of nationhood,
然而，这并不是人们在美国通常如何铭记这场被称为1812年战争的冲突的。是的，我正要说这个。人们根本不是那样记忆它的。我的意思是，在英国，坦率地说，我认为在普通公众中，在那些不是历史迷的人中间，这件事情简直完全被遗忘了。是的。但在美国，它被铭记为一个建立国家的伟大时刻，
isn't it? For two reasons. And the first is that in the 14th of September, 1814, the British attack Baltimore and they bombard this fort, Fort McHenry. And there's a huge US flag, 15 stars on it. And it flutters throughout the bombardment and then the British withdraw. And this inspires a poem, which is then set to music.
不是吗？原因有两个。第一个是，在1814年9月14日，英国人进攻巴尔的摩，他们轰炸了这个堡垒——麦克亨利堡。那里有一面巨大的美国国旗，上面有15颗星。它在轰炸中一直飘扬，然后英国人撤退了。这激发了一首诗的灵感，这首诗后来被谱成了曲。
And in 1931, this song becomes the US National Anthem. And that, of course, is the Star Spangled Banner. Yes. So the US National Anthem commemorates a kind of defiance, a display of defiance against the British. And actually this is very British behaviour, isn't it? Because, you know, making a victory out of a defeat
1931年，这首歌成为了美国的国歌。当然，这就是《星条旗》。是的。所以美国国歌纪念了一种反抗，一种对英国的反抗。实际上这非常符合英国人的行为模式，不是吗？因为，你知道，化失败为胜利
is basically what we do. It's kind of Dunkirk and all that kind of thing. But what's very satisfying about that is that the Star Spangled Banner, the tune is actually an old british song from a london club i think the the anachriontic society which was some sort of 18th century dining club or 19th century dining club or something yeah so it's nice to think that the the american national anthem is actually british exactly exactly yeah um and the other reason why the totality of British supremacy in the 1812 war is forgotten is that the conflict actually ends with a ringing British defeat. And this occurs after the peace treaty has actually been signed, but the news of grabbing hold of Louisiana. The Americans are under the command of a man called Andrew Jackson, and he inflicts an absolutely stinging defeat. So about 2000 British soldiers die. And this is, I think, about half an hour of action.
基本上就是我们的拿手好戏。这有点像敦刻尔克和诸如此类的事情。但最让人满意的是，《星条旗》的曲调其实是一首来自伦敦一个俱乐部的老英国歌，我想是饮宴诗社（Anacreontic Society），这是一个18世纪或19世纪的餐饮俱乐部什么的。所以想到美国国歌实际上是英国的，就觉得很有意思。完全正确，是的。嗯，另一个为什么1812年战争中英国绝对优势地位被遗忘的原因是，这场冲突实际上以英国人的一次惨败告终。而这发生在和平条约实际签署之后，但当时消息还没传开，英国人试图夺取路易斯安那。美国人在一个叫安德鲁·杰克逊的人的指挥下，给予了英军毁灭性的打击。大约有2000名英国士兵阵亡。我想这大概只用了半小时的战斗。
Americans lose about 70 men. And this is tremendous for the Americans. So they make a great fuss of it. Jackson becomes a great hero. The 8th of January becomes a federal holiday. Hurrah, hurrah for Andrew Jackson. Hurrah for America. But anyway, I think that that war kind of perfectly illustrates the way in which smaller powers confronted by superpowers will invariably inflate their successes and their triumphs. You're really endearing us to our American audience. Well, no, because it will turn around, of course. Of course it will. You know, I'm merely, this is the hubris that precedes the nemesis. The nemesis is coming. So 1812, 1814, that shows Britain and America not as the best of friends.
美国人大约损失了70人。这对美国人来说太棒了。所以他们大肆庆祝。杰克逊成了伟大的英雄。1月8日成了联邦假日。乌拉，为安德鲁·杰克逊乌拉。为美国乌拉。不过无论如何，我认为那场战争完美地说明了这样一种方式：面对超级大国的小国，总是会夸大自己的成功和胜利。你可真讨我们的美国听众喜欢啊。噢，不，因为局势会反转的，当然会的。你知道的，我只是——这是傲慢导致毁灭。毁灭就要来临了。所以1812年、1814年，展现的并非最好的朋友般的英美关系。
But the truth is that, of course, they're both English-speaking nations. The cultural links are incredibly strong. British writers, for instance, are very, very widely read in the United States. And by the 1840s, American writers are starting to be read in Britain as well. But still, the cultural preponderance is all on Britain's side. And in 1842, the most famous novelist in Britain, perhaps in the world, makes a trip to the United States, and that is Charles Dickens. Brilliant.
但事实是，当然，它们都是英语国家。文化联系极其强大。例如，英国作家在美国被广泛阅读。到了19世纪40年代，美国作家也开始在英国被人阅读。但文化的主导权依然完全在英国一边。1842年，英国乃至全世界最著名的作家踏上了去美国的旅程，他就是查尔斯·狄更斯。太棒了。
And Charles Dickens sails to America. There's a number of reasons why he wants to go. The first is basically that he is very popular. The Americans see him as being almost an honorary American. So they call him the great Republican of the literary world. So Dickens, who loves praise, who loves performing, thinks, well, I can be tasted by the Americans. What could be nicer? He also has, there are copyright issues. So American publishers are stealing British editions and publishing them so dickens doesn't get any royalties yeah again dickens is always very keen on maximizing his income so he wants to go and sort that out he also uh he wants material for a book he thinks that going to america might be you know provide him with uh interesting material uh and he wants
查尔斯·狄更斯乘船前往美国。他想去有很多原因。首先是他非常受欢迎。美国人视他几乎为荣誉美国人。所以他们称他为“文学世界的伟大共和党人”。所以狄更斯，一个热爱赞美、热爱表演的人，心想，好吧，我可以去接受美国人的品味品评了。还有什么比这更好的呢？他还有版权问题。所以美国出版商在偷印英国版本并出版，导致狄更斯拿不到版税。是的，狄更斯一向热衷于最大化他的收入，所以他想去解决这个问题。他还想为一本书搜集材料，他觉得去美国可能会为他提供有趣的材料，
a break you know he's been writing non-stop yeah and so he dickens's idea wants a break. You know, he's been writing nonstop. And so Dickens' idea of a break is to cross the Atlantic in the middle of January when the storms are particularly violent. So he sets off with his wife. The cabin is way too small. The storms are absolutely terrible. He's on a steamer and the smokestack is um is so battered about by the gales that it has to be chained down to stop it blowing over and setting the ship on on fire uh
而且他想休息一下，你知道，他一直在马不停蹄地写作。所以狄更斯对休息的理解就是在一月中旬暴风雨特别猛烈的时候横渡大西洋。于是他带上了妻子出发了。船舱实在太小了。风暴极其可怕。他坐的是一艘汽轮，烟囱被狂风摧毁得不成样子，不得不被铁链固定住，以防它被吹倒并引发船只火灾。
they reach newfoundland and run aground um so it's all it's a terrible terrible voyage so when they finally arrive in boston where dickens first steps foot on uh soil. He's very much in a mood to enjoy himself. And so he really likes Boston. He's greeted with adulation and he loves that. He goes on to New York where they stage a Boz Ball. So Boz is the pseudonym that Dickens has been using. And it's attended by 3,000 people. And another 2,000 people had applied for tickets. That's a bit like the rest is history live, Tom. Very live. Well, so here's something for us to aim at.
他们到达纽芬兰并搁浅了——所以这是一次糟糕透顶的航行。当他们终于到达狄更斯首次踏上陆地的波士顿时，他非常渴望好好享受一番。所以他真的很喜欢波士顿。人们夹道欢迎他，他很喜欢这种感觉。他继续前往纽约，在那里他们举办了一场“博兹舞会”（Boz Ball）。因为“博兹”是狄更斯一直使用的笔名。有3000人出席。另外还有2000人申请了门票。这有点像我们的“历史的 rest is history”现场秀，汤姆。非常现场。好吧，这给我们树立了一个目标。
When Dickens appears at this boss ball, he does so on the arm of a general who is in his full dress uniform. And as they enter, the band plays See the Conquering Hero Comes. We have to do a live event where we enter stage like that yeah yeah um and and so dick is his herring around new york he's doing what he always does which is to visit various institutions that could provide him with material for his book so he visits prisons factories asylums slums all these kind of stuff uh and he also meets some of america's most famous writers so he he meets edgar allen poe he uh he meets washington irving who's an absolutely massive
当狄更斯出现在这个博兹舞会上时，他是挽着一位身穿全套礼服的将军走进来的。他们一进场，乐队就奏起了《看征服的英雄归来》。我们以后办现场活动也得这样登场才行，对吧？对的，然后狄更斯在纽约到处跑，他做着他一直在做的事，那就是参观各种能为他的书提供材料的机构。所以他参观了监狱、工厂、收容所、贫民窟，所有这些地方。他还见了美国一些最著名的作家——他见到了埃德加·爱伦·坡，他见到了华盛顿·欧文，后者是一个超级
fan boy washington irving is i mean absolutely devoted to dickens i think he'd met longfellow in boston right so it all seems to be going well also on top of that his wife catherine to whom dickens normally paves abominably because he finds her boring and she's constantly pregnant but she's not pregnant on the trip to america and dick she's basically the main focus of dickens's attentions and so this is probably the happiest that they you know the time that they spend together right so it all seems to be going well but as as the weeks and then the months pass, Dickens starts to get increasingly disenchanted with America. He starts to get bored of the fuss.
狂热粉，华盛顿·欧文简直对狄更斯崇拜得五体投地。我想他在波士顿还见过朗费罗。所以一切看起来都很顺利。除此之外，他的妻子凯瑟琳——狄更斯平时对她态度恶劣，因为他觉得她很无聊，而且她经常怀孕，但这次去美国她没有怀孕，狄更斯基本上把主要的注意力都放在了她身上。所以这可能是他们度过的最快乐的一段时光了。所以一切看起来都很顺利，但随着几周甚至几个月的过去，狄更斯开始对美国感到越来越幻灭。他开始厌倦大惊小怪的人群。
People are always asking him for autographs, that kind of thing. And he's starting to get bored of it. In England, he can always retreat, but in America, he can't. And the strain starts to get on top of him. And also his insistence on demanding the copyright law be changed. It's absolutely dead batted. The Americans are not interested in hearing about this. And so Dickens gets increasingly cross. And again, it becomes a kind of massive flare point. And so by the time that Dickens goes to Washington, where he meets the president,
人们总是在向他索要签名之类的。他开始对此感到厌烦。在英国，他总是可以退居幕后，但在美国，他不能。这种压力开始让他难以承受。而且他坚持要求修改版权法。却遭到了冷遇。美国人根本不感兴趣听这些。所以狄更斯越来越生气。同样，这也成了一个巨大的冲突爆发点。因此，当狄更斯去华盛顿拜访总统时，
John Tyler, and Dickens finds him very polite, but incredibly boring. I think John Tyler is incredibly boring. Well, but say we went to the United States, we went to Washington. Yeah.
约翰·泰勒，狄更斯发现他非常有礼貌，但极其无聊。我觉得约翰·泰勒极其无聊。好吧，假设我们去了美国，我们去了华盛顿。是的。
And we got an invitation to go to the white house. Absolutely plausible. You'd go, wouldn't you? Yeah, I would. I'd go. I mean,
我们收到了去白宫的邀请。完全有可能。你会去的，对吧？对，我会的。我会去的。我的意思是，
you might not think, yeah, you'd go if it was Trump, you'd go if it was Biden, you'd go whoever. I mean, ideally it wouldn't be Trump,, I would. I'd go whoever. I mean, you might not think. Yeah. You'd go if it was Trump. You'd go if it was Biden. You'd go whoever. I mean, ideally, it wouldn't be Trump, but I would still go. But you'd still go, wouldn't you? I think.
你可能不会觉得——是的，如果是特朗普你会去，如果是拜登你会去，无论谁你都会去。我的意思是，理想情况下不是特朗普，但我还是会去。但你还是会去的，对吧？我想。
I would. I would. No question. Yeah. Because you just, so you could kind of, you know, say that I'm gone or something. Yeah. Yeah.
我会的。我绝对会。毫无疑问。是的。因为你只是，为了可以，你知道的，说我去过或者别的什么。是的。是的。
Exactly. Take a fork. Exactly. But Dickens refuses. He can't be bothered. Well, that's why he's Charles Dickens and I'm not, I suppose. He thinks it's going to be boring. And when he goes on into Virginia and he hates it.
完全正确。拿个叉子。完全正确。但狄更斯拒绝了。他才懒得去。好吧，这就是为什么他是查尔斯·狄更斯而我不是，我想。他觉得会很无聊。当他继续前往弗吉尼亚时，他讨厌那里。
So he says. Virginia is very nice, Tom. I think that's folly on Dickens' part. Yeah. Okay. But this is the spin that Dickens gives to Virginia. He describes it as the regions of slavery, spittoons and senators. All three are evils in all countries. And he's right about the slavery and probably about the spittoons and senators all three are evils in all countries and he's right about the
所以他说。弗吉尼亚非常不错，汤姆。我觉得那是狄更斯的糊涂之举。好吧。但这是狄更斯对弗吉尼亚的评价。他将其描述为“奴隶制、痰盂和参议员的地区”。这三者在所有国家都是恶疾。他说得对，关于奴隶制，可能关于痰盂和参议员也对，这三者在所有国家都是恶疾，他说的关于
slavery and probably about the spittoons so he's he's particularly revolt it's the slavery that really upsets him and actually revolts him so much that he he retreats from virginia and heads back to pennsylvania and essentially it turns him and he he ends up hostile to pretty much everything that he sees in America. So he goes to the Mississippi. He describes it as the beastliest river in the world. He goes to the Midwest and he magnificently, he says of the Midwest, I would say to everyone who can't see a prairie, go to Salisbury Plain. Oh, no way. Some of you must be delighted by that.
奴隶制是对的，关于痰盂大概也是对的。所以他特别反感——真正让他心烦甚至作呕的是奴隶制，以至于他从弗吉尼亚撤退，返回宾夕法尼亚，基本上这让他变得对他在美国看到的一切都充满敌意。所以他去了密西西比河。他将其描述为“世界上最令人作呕的河流”。他去了中西部，最妙的是，他对中西部说：“我要对每一个没见过草原的人说，去索尔兹伯里平原吧。”噢，不会吧。你们中肯定有人会为此高兴的。
Yeah, absolutely delighted um if we have any listeners in ohio in ohio um yeah of the people of ohio he describes them as morose sullen clownish and repulsive so he's he's appalled not just by slavery but by treatment of native americans who he describes as a fine people but degraded and broken down. And so basically within a few months, he's absolutely desperate to get back to England and he goes via Canada. So he goes to the Niagara Falls, he goes to Toronto, then to New York and heads back across the Atlantic, back to Liverpool.
是的，绝对高兴。如果我们有任何俄亥俄州的听众的话，在俄亥俄州。是的，对于俄亥俄州的人，他把他们描述为“阴郁、暴躁、丑角般且令人反感”。所以他不仅对奴隶制感到震惊，而且对印第安人的待遇也感到震惊，他把他们描述为“一个优秀的民族，却被贬低和摧毁了”。所以基本上在几个月内，他绝对渴望回到英国，他经由加拿大回去。所以他去了尼亚加拉大瀑布，去了多伦多，然后去了纽约，横渡大西洋回到了利物浦。
And he's so delighted to be heading back to England that all his spirits recover. He entertains himself and his fellow passengers by playing an accordion. And he organizes a club in which all the members of the club have to dress up as doctors. And then go around. Apparently, they go around pretending to cure people who are sick. They'll go and pretend to be doctors and pretend to cure them, which Dickens thought was absolutely hilarious.
他太高兴能回英国了，以至于精神全都恢复了。他通过拉手风琴来娱乐自己和同船的乘客。他还组织了一个俱乐部，俱乐部的所有成员都必须扮成医生。然后四处走动。显然，他们到处假装给生病的人看病。他们会去假装是医生并假装治愈他们，狄更斯觉得这简直滑稽透顶。
Oh, my word. That's surely – you're sent to prison for that these days. Yes, but for Dickens – I mean, this is absolutely the kind of thing Dickens adored. So he gets back to England, and basically the bad blood between Dickens and America persists. So the Americans have continued to refuse to sort out the copyright issue, and it remains an issue for British writers right the way up until 1891. Well, Gerard Tolkien, The Lord of the Rings, that was ripped off, wasn't it? Yeah, it was. I mean, by that point, there was a formal relationship, a formal legal agreement,
天哪。这绝对——现在这样是要被送进监狱的。是的，但对狄更斯来说——我的意思是，这绝对是狄更斯最喜欢的消遣。所以他回到了英国，基本上狄更斯和美国之间的恶劣关系一直在延续。美国人继续拒绝解决版权问题，这个问题一直持续到1891年，仍然是英国作家的一个大问题。嗯，杰拉德·托尔金的《指环王》，那部作品也被盗版了，不是吗？是的，确实如此。我的意思是，到那个时候，已经有了正式的关系、正式的法律协议，
but absolutely, the tradition of copyright infringements continues, as you say, right the way past the Second World War. Dickens then writes a couple of books that cause immense upset in America. So one of them is American Notes, which is basically a description of his journey. It has a vituperative attack on the institution of slavery. But it also condemns the Americans in ways that, as the passage that you opened this episode with, the passage from Macmillan suggests, the kind of stereotypes of Americans that the British have always held to, that they're vulgar, that they are crass, that they throw their weight around. It's basically this old world hauteur.
但绝对地，正如你所说的，侵犯版权的传统一直延续到了二战以后。狄更斯随后写了几本书，在美国引起了轩然大波。其中一本是《美国纪行》，基本上是对他旅程的描述。书中对奴隶制这一制度进行了恶毒的攻击。但它也以麦克麦克米伦在本集开场所引用的那种方式谴责美国人，正如麦克米伦所暗示的那样，英国人对美国人一向抱有的刻板印象是：他们很粗俗，他们很愚蠢，他们盛气凌人。这基本上就是老派欧洲人的高傲。
These people are upstarts. Yeah. And Poe, who's a big fan of Dickens, is so offended by it that he describes it basically as Dickens' suicide note, you know, for his popularity in America. Yeah. Dickens then writes, he's writing a novel called Martin Chuzzlewit. It's not going very well.
这些人不过是暴发户。是的。而爱伦·坡作为狄更斯的铁杆粉丝，对此深感冒犯，以至于他基本上把这本书描述为狄更斯的“自杀信”（即他在美国受欢迎程度的自杀）。是的。狄更斯随后写了一部名为《马丁·查述伟》的小说。进展不太顺利。
It's his least popular novel. And so he decides that to try and pep things up, he'll send his hero, Martin Chuzzlewit, off to America for no apparent reason. I mean, he just goes off to America. And the chapters on America are actually incredibly funny. The Americans are the most dreadful caricatures, though, aren't they?
这是他最不受欢迎的小说。因此他决定振作一下，把他的英雄马丁·查述伟无缘无故地派往美国。我的意思是，他就是去了美国。而关于美国的章节其实非常有趣。不过，美国人被刻画成了极其可怕的讽刺形象，不是吗？
They really are. And again, people in America take massive offense. And even Washington Irving, this time, breaks off his friendship. So basically, Dickens' portrait of New York is a city where everyone spits. That's the main focus. And again, it's this sense that Americans are obsessed by money, which you might think coming from Dickens, who'd come over specifically to complain that he wasn't getting enough money. But he talks about the conversation in America as being the greater part of it
确实如此。再次地，美国人受到了极大的冒犯。甚至华盛顿·欧文这次也与他断交了。基本上，狄更斯笔下的纽约是一个每个人都在随地吐痰的城市。这是主要的焦点。同样，这种感觉是美国人痴迷于金钱，你可能会觉得，这话从狄更斯嘴里说出来很讽刺，因为他就是专程来抱怨自己没拿到足够多的钱的。但他谈到美国的谈话时说，其中大部分内容
may be summed up in one word, dollars. All their cares, hopes, joys, affections, virtues, and associations seem to be melted down into dollars. Whatever the chance contributions that fell into the slow cauldron of their talk, they made the gruel thick and slab with dollars. Men were weighed by their dollars, measures gauged by their dollars. Life was auctioneered, appraised, put up and knocked down for its dollars. And that, I mean, that again is a kind of an abiding critique that the British will have.
可以用一个词来概括：美元。他们所有的关切、希望、快乐、情感、美德和交往，似乎都融化成了美元。无论什么偶然的言论落入他们谈话的缓慢大熔炉中，都会让这碗稀粥变得浓稠沉甸，里面塞满了美元。人们以美元来衡量，措施以美元来标尺。生活被拿去拍卖、评估、叫价并因美元而敲锤成交。这，我的意思是，这再次是英国人挥之不去的批判。
We'll be coming back to that in the last moments of this program, Tom, when we get to the late 20th century. And we will be coming to it in my third vignette, which shows the corollary of the almighty dollar, which is that by the end of the 19th century, the economic balance of power between Britain and America is starting to shift. And perhaps the paradigmatic illustration of this is a man who becomes at one point the richest in the world, but who originally came from Scotland, from Dunfermline, Andrew Carnegie, who's born in 1835. But when he's 12, so in 1848, he emigrates to Pittsburgh with his family. And he begins right at the bottom. He kind of works in a cotton mill. He works as a telegraph operator. But over the course of his life,
汤姆，我们将在本节目的最后时刻再次谈到这一点，当我们谈到20世纪后期的时候。我们将在我的第三个小故事中谈到它，它展示了万能美元的必然结果，那就是到19世纪末，英美之间的经济权力对比开始发生转变。也许这方面最典型的例子是一个曾经成为世界上最富有的人，但最初来自苏格兰邓弗姆林的安德鲁·卡内基，他出生于1835年。当他12岁时，即1848年，他随家人移民到匹兹堡。他从最底层干起。他在棉纺厂工作，当过电报员。但在他的一生中，
he proves himself brilliant at capitalism. And he ends up this huge monopolist. And he, in a way, embodies American capitalism at its most brutal and aggressive. So he crushes all his rivals. He smashes unions. I mean, he's an absolutely unapologetic monopolist. All rivals are there to be destroyed. And he is not a great man for indiscriminate charity, which he sees as fostering laziness and drunkenness. And yet for all that, he remains the child of his Presbyterian upbringing. And that Presbyterian upbringing, that kind of radical Protestant sense is something that of course is common to both sides of the Atlantic. It's there in Britain, it's there in the United States. And in 1889, Carnegie publishes a track called The Gospel of Wealth, where he basically makes the argument that it's the duty of people to get incredibly rich so that they can then reinvest their money in ways that won't kind of relieve poverty per se, but will enable the poor to improve themselves. Basically, it's
他证明了自己是个资本主义天才。他最终成了一个庞大的垄断者。从某种意义上说，他体现了最残酷、最具侵略性的美洲资本主义。所以他粉碎了所有的竞争对手，砸碎了工会。我的意思是，他是一个毫不掩饰的垄断者。所有的对手都是用来摧毁的。他不热衷于无差别的慈善事业，他认为那会助长懒惰和酗酒。然而尽管如此，他依然保持着长老会 upbringing（成长背景）的孩子。而这种长老会背景，那种激进的新教意识，当然是大西洋两岸所共有的。它存在于英国，也存在于美国。1889年，卡内基发表了一篇名为《财富的福音》的文章，他在文中基本上提出了这样的观点：人们有责任变得极其富有，然后以某种方式将钱重新投资，这些方式虽然不一定直接救济贫困，但能使穷人自我完善。基本上就是
the duty of the rich to get rich so that they can provide ladders for other people to then climb up and also become rich. And this is very American, I think. And it's one that Carnegie is so rich. So he ends up selling or basically selling off all his companies to John Pierpont Morgan, which he does in 1901, by which point he's basically the richest man in the world. And he then uses the money. He invests in parks, libraries, schools, and Carnegie institutions are, you know, they're not just in the United States. They're also across the world and particularly in Britain. So he reinvests in Britain. And the British have their eyes opened both to the sheer scale of the American economy.
富人有责任去致富，这样他们才能为其他人提供阶梯，让他们也能往上爬并变得富有。我认为这非常具有美国特色。这也是为什么卡耐基如此富有。所以他最终在 1901 年卖掉了他所有的公司，或者基本上是卖给了约翰·皮尔庞特·摩根，到那时他基本上已经是世界上最富有的人了。然后他用这笔钱进行投资。他投资公园、图书馆、学校，卡耐基机构，你知道，它们不仅在美国，而且遍布世界各地，特别是在英国。所以他在英国重新投资。英国人也大开眼界，看到了美国经济的庞大规模。
You know, they're so accustomed to thinking of themselves as the great economic power that I think that Carnegie's, the dispensing of Carnegie's largesse kind of opens their eyes to the sheer scale of what is happening. The industrial economic financial power is leaking across the Atlantic to the United States. But also what they find impressive is the scale of Carnegie's generosity. And I think that that is also a way that the British see the Americans, is there's a respect for the principle of charity of their rich. I mean, there's an absolute sense that rich Americans tend to be more generous. Yeah, no, that's absolutely the case now, Tom. I mean, I've written columns about it. Why don't British billionaires hand out as much money as Americans do? And the explanation, I think, is largely cultural. It's just a thing that americans are expected to do and then britain they're not well carnegie is the archetype and maybe the trendsetter for this and the embodiment i think of of all these trends the ways in which um the lead is passing from britain to america the child is starting to school the parent right the disciple is starting to
你知道，他们习惯了认为自己是伟大的经济强国，我认为卡耐基发放卡耐基式的慷慨解囊，让他们的眼界大开，看到了正在发生的事情的庞大规模。工业、经济和金融权力正在向大西洋彼岸的美国流失。但同样让他们印象深刻的是卡耐基慷慨解囊的规模。我认为这也是英国人看待美国人的一种方式，他们尊重富人的慈善原则。我的意思是，有一种绝对的共识，即美国富人往往更大方。是的，不，汤姆，现在绝对是这样。我的意思是，我写过关于这个主题的专栏。为什么英国亿万富翁不像美国人那样分发那么多钱？我想，其中的解释在很大程度上是文化的。这只是美国人被期望去做的事情，而在英国则不然。好吧，卡耐基是这方面的原型，也许是潮流的引领者，我认为他是所有这些潮流的化身，是领导权从英国传给美国的各种方式，孩子开始教育父母了，对吧，门徒开始
school the master darth vader and obi-wan kenobi tom a comparison you have made before um comes in the 12th of may 1905 when andrew carnegie visits the natural history museum in london where a huge cast of a dinosaur fossil is a is unveiled this dinosaur fossil is one that was in the Natural History Museum until a very few years ago. It's a Diplodocus, which is a sauropod, a very long neck, very long tail. When it was found, it was described as the most colossal animal ever on earth. And this is why Carnegie wanted it, because it seemed to embody his own, the massive scale of his own ambitions, his own fortune. And so he donates the
教育师父了——达斯·维达和欧比旺·克诺比，汤姆，这是你之前做过的一个比较，发生在使用于 1905 年 5 月 12 日，当时安德鲁·卡耐基访问了伦敦自然历史博物馆，在那里揭幕了一个巨大的恐龙化石模型。这个恐龙化石直到几年前还一直在自然历史博物馆里。它是一只梁龙，属于蜥脚类恐龙，脖子很长，尾巴很长。当它被发现时，它被描述为地球上有史以来最庞大的动物。这就是卡耐基想要它的原因，因为它似乎体现了他自己的野心、他自己的巨额财富的庞大规模。所以他把这具
actual fossil to a very lavishly appointed museum in his own hometown of Pittsburgh. But he also makes casts of it and sends it around the world. But the first one he sends is to Britain. And he gives a speech at the Natural History Museum when it's unveiled. And he is unapologetic about what it is that has enabled him to make his gift. He says that, you know, it is my commitment to making money. It's his unfettered accumulation of capital that had enabled him to fund this gift to the British people. But he also says that he is giving it to serve as a physical embodiment of the links between the British and American peoples. And he wants this dinosaur to serve as an emblem of an alliance for peace. And I guess that Carnegie, to that extent, is the embodiment of the future, that Anglophobia will persist in the
真正的化石捐赠给了他自己家乡匹兹堡的一座装饰极其豪华的博物馆。但他也制作了复制品，并将其运往世界各地。不过他寄出的第一个是给英国的。当它揭幕时，他在自然历史博物馆发表了一讲。对于是什么让他能够做出这份礼物，他毫不掩饰。他说，你知道，这是我对赚钱的承诺。正是他对资本不受限制的累积，使他能够资助这份送给英国人民的礼物。但他也表示，他是为了将其作为英国和美国人民之间联系的物理实体而赠送的。他希望这条恐龙能够成为和平联盟的象征。我想，从这个程度来说，卡耐基是未来的化身，而仇英情绪将在
United States. Obviously, lots of people from Ireland have emigrated to the United States, and that has added for the good of the world if they were to coexist, not just in peace and friendship. And in the decades that follow, that friendship will start to develop, most notably by the fact that America, although entering the war late, will enter the First World War on the side of Britain. Yeah. So when Carnegie, I guess, is making his money, the future president, Woodrow Wilson, is reciting Gladstone speeches by heart in front of the mirror to teach himself how to be a political orator. Obviously, Wilson is the guy who takes the US into the First World War. And with that, I guess that first wartime collaboration is the moment when the relationship starts to converge politically, if you like. The key thing about that dinosaur, Tom,
美国持续存在。显然，许多来自爱尔兰的人移民到了美国，如果他们能够和平与友谊并存，而不仅仅是，那将对世界有益。在随后的几十年里，这种友谊开始发展，最显着的表现是美国虽然参战较晚，但最终还是站在英国一边参加了第一次世界大战。是的。所以当卡耐基在赚钱的时候，未来的总统伍德罗·威尔逊正在镜子前背诵格莱斯顿的演讲，来教自己如何成为一名政治演说家。显然，威尔逊就是把美国带入第一次世界大战的人。有了这个，我想第一次战时的合作就是两国的关系开始在政治上趋同的时刻，如果你愿意的话。关于那只恐龙的关键点，汤姆，
that is the dinosaur that is stolen in the excellent film, One of Our Dinosaurs is Missing. Yeah. Peter Ustinov steals it, doesn't he? I think that film is almost certainly deemed inappropriate for young people today. And the dinosaur has been removed. Am I right?
那就是在优秀电影《我们的一只恐龙失踪了》中被偷的那只恐龙。是的。彼得·乌斯蒂诺夫偷了它，对吧？我认为这部电影在今天几乎肯定会被认为对年轻人不合适。而且那只恐龙已经被移走了。我说的对吗？
Why has the dinosaur been removed? So it's been replaced by the skeleton of a blue whale. um there was a feeling that uh to have the skeleton of a whale would better convey messages of protecting the environment okay fair enough than a cast given by an american plutocrat well the whale is brilliant i mean yeah the natural history museum the whale is brilliant okay fantastic tom that was really, really interesting. That's a hard act to follow, but follow it, I will, after the break. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde.
为什么那只恐龙被移走了？所以它被一具蓝鲸的骨架取代了；有人觉得，放一具鲸鱼骨架能更好地传达保护环境的信息，好吧，这倒也合理，总比一个美国财阀送的复制品要好。嗯，那条鲸鱼太棒了，我是说，是的，自然历史博物馆的那条鲸鱼太棒了。好吧，太棒了，汤姆，这真的非常非常有趣。这是一个很难超越的表现，但中场休息后，我会试着超越它的。一会见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Yeehaw! We are talking America and we're talking specifically america's relationship with england and dominic in the first half we were looking at a century where britain definitely was the uh the larger player yeah now we're moving into the 20th century and sad to say america is very much
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告的节目、获得额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。耶哈！我们在谈论美国，我们具体在谈论美国与英国的关系，多米尼克，在上半场，我们回顾了一个英国绝对是，呃，更具优势的玩家的世纪。是的，现在我们正进入 20世纪，遗憾地说，美国在很大程度上
overtaking us top dog it is top dog it's. It's top nation. Well, Tom, fantastic. Yeehaw. Thank you. Congratulations on that. I think everyone will have enjoyed that. Yes. So we ended the first half talking about, um, uh,
超越了我们，成了老大，它就是老大。它是头号国家。好吧，汤姆，太棒了。耶哈。谢谢。祝贺你取得这个成绩。我想大家都会喜欢的。是的。所以我们在上半场结束时谈到了，呃，
the coming of the world wars and how that marks a sort of political convergence. Um, and, and I suppose most people listening to this think I'm going to do FDR and Churchill, Thatcher and Reagan, Blair and his very tight trousers, and George Bush.
世界大战的到来，以及这如何标志着一种政治上的趋同。嗯，而且，我想大多数听到这里的人都会以为我要讲罗斯福和丘吉尔、撒切尔和里根、穿着紧身裤的布莱尔和乔治·布什。
Remember he wore those inappropriately tight jeans? And he aped Bush's walk, didn't he? He did. And aped is the word. Yeah. All kinds of naturalists talked about how the leader of ape troops inspire their inferiors to copy them and coming from from tony blair's greatest admirer i mean that is that is pretty damning it was a painful moment uh what it was literally must have been an incredibly painful moment for him judging by his trousers anyway listen um let's move to the second world war let's start in the second one where i've chosen three light time slightly elliptical moments pearl harbor obviously happens at the end of 1941. So up until that point, the United States has not been directly
还记得他穿的那种极其不合时宜的紧身牛仔裤吗？他还模仿了布什的走路方式，不是吗？他确实模仿了。而“模仿”这个词用得很贴切。是的。各种自然主义者都谈到过猴群的首领如何激励其下属去模仿它们，这出自托尼·布莱尔最崇拜的人之口，我的意思是，这真的是相当致命的贬低。那是一个痛苦的时刻，呃，这字面意思上一定对他来说是个极其痛苦的时刻，从他的裤子来看不管怎样，听着，嗯，让我们转到第二次世界大战，让我们从第二个开始，我选择了一些轻松的、略带椭圆形的时刻。珍珠港事件显然发生在 1941 年底。所以在此之前，美国并没有直接
involved in the Second World War, certainly not in the war in Europe, other than kind of very, very indirectly. And GIs, American GIs start to arrive in Britain pretty soon thereafter. So the first GIs arrive in January 1942. And in total, their numbers rise to 3 million people. I mean, this is by far the single biggest movement of Americans to Britain in history. They are admired and resented by the locals in equal measure. The joke is, of course, that all the girls can't get enough of them with their chewing gum and their gifts of nylon stockings and chocolate and all these sort of things. So the joke is that when you're wearing your wartime underwear that you've been given in Britain because of rationing called utility knickers, they're called utility knickers, one yank and they're off. Very good.
参与第二次世界大战，当然也没有参与欧洲的战争，除了那种非常非常间接的方式。此后不久，美国大兵（GIs）开始抵达英国。因此，首批美国大兵于 1942 年 1 月抵达。他们的总人数上升到了 300 万人。我的意思是，这是有史以来美国人向英国最大规模的单次迁移。当地人对他们既钦佩又怨恨。当然，笑话是，所有的姑娘们都对他们百看不厌，带着他们的口香糖、尼龙长袜、巧克力以及诸如此类的礼物。所以这个笑话是，当你在英国因为物资配给而穿着被称为实用内裤（utility knickers）的战时内衣时——它们被称为实用内裤——只要美国佬轻轻一拉，它们就脱掉了。非常好。
Very good. Great banter. George Orwell writes about this in one of his columns. He says, it's difficult to go anywhere in London without having the feeling that Britain is now occupied territory. The general consensus of opinion, Orwell adds, seems to be that the only American soldiers with decent manners are the Negroes. Now, this is the theme that I want to talk about, because actually, so far, we haven't talked about black Americans. But of those 3 million Americans who arrive in Britain, just under 150,000 there or thereabouts are black. And they work in labor companies, or they work in transport or as
非常棒。精彩的俏皮话。乔治·奥威尔在他的专栏中写到了这一点。他说，在伦敦无论走到哪里，都很难不产生一种英国现在是沦陷区的感觉。奥威尔补充说，普遍的共识似乎是，唯一有礼貌的美国士兵是黑人。现在，这是我想谈的主题，因为到目前为止，我们实际上还没有谈论过黑人美国人。但在抵达英国的 300 万美国人中，大约有不到 15 万人是黑人。他们在劳工连工作，或者在运输部门工作，或者作为
engineers. They're not generally frontline troops and certainly not officers. So what did the British make of them? Obviously, Britain has an empire. And for that reason, there's all kinds of assumptions and prejudices sort of floating around in the imaginations, in the subconscious, or indeed the consciousness of ordinary Britons. Most ordinary Britons have probably never seen a black man. So they may have done if they live in Liverpool or in London or in some sort of port, Bristol, for example. But if you're out, you know, in this sort of, in the hinterland, in deep England, then you almost certainly haven't. There is, interestingly, despite the fact that Britain, you know,
工程师。他们通常不是一线部队，更不用说军官了。那么英国人对他们有什么看法呢？显然，英国拥有一个帝国。正因为如此，在普通英国人的想象中、在潜意识中，甚至是在意识中，流淌着各种各样的假设和偏见。大多数普通英国人可能从未见过黑人。所以如果他们住在利物浦、伦敦或某些港口（例如布里斯托尔），他们可能见过。但如果你在那种内陆深处、英格兰腹地，那么你几乎肯定没见过。有趣的是，尽管英国，呃，
rules India, has both participated in and then abolished the slave trade, that there is a kind of racial hierarchy within the British Empire. There is a sense in Britain that Americans are racist and that that is a sort of vulgar thing to be. Well, that's what Dickens hated. Right. So, I mean, Dr. Johnson had talked about this in the 18th century. Dickens talked about it even in children's stories.
统治着印度，既参与了后来又废除了奴隶贸易，但在大英帝国内部存在着一种种族等级制度。英国有一种看法，即美国人是种族主义者，这是一种粗俗的行为。好吧，这就是狄更斯所痛恨的。没错。所以，我的意思是，约翰逊博士在 18 世纪就谈论过这一点。狄更斯甚至在童话故事中也谈到了这一点。
So I've talked before in this podcast about how I love the Billy Bunter stories set at Greyfriars School, sort of Edwardian boarding school stories. In those stories, an American boy arrives one day. He's called Fisher T. Fish. All he cares about, Tom, is, you guessed it, money. He's incredibly avaricious. So these are stories written for British schoolboy readers or schoolgirl readers. Fisher T. Fish is not merely avaricious. So these are stories written for British schoolboy readers or schoolgirl readers. Fisher T. Fish is not merely avaricious. He is racist.
所以我之前在这个播客中谈过我有多么喜欢以格雷弗赖尔学校为背景的比利·班特（Billy Bunter）故事，这是一种爱德华时代的寄宿学校故事。在这些故事中，有一天来了一个美国男孩。他叫费舍尔·T·菲什（Fisher T. Fish）。汤姆，他关心的全部就是，你猜对了，钱。他极其贪婪。所以这些是为英国男校学生或女校学生写的故事。费舍尔·T·菲什不仅贪婪。所以这些是为英国男校学生或女校学生写的故事。费舍尔·T·菲什不仅贪婪。他还是个种族主义者。
There's an Indian boy, for example, at the school who the British boys call Inky, but he's a great friend of theirs. He's a great cricketer, Tom. You'll be pleased to hear. He's modeled on Ranjit Singh, isn't he? He is indeed. Fisher T. Fish at first is quite racist towards him, and the other boys say, oh, we know you'll be racist, of course,
例如，学校里有一个印度男孩，英国男孩们叫他“墨水瓶”（Inky），但他却是他们的好朋友。他是个出色的板球运动员，汤姆。你听了会高兴的。他是以兰吉特·辛格为原型的，对吧？他的确是的。费舍尔·T·菲什起初对他的态度相当种族主义，其他男孩说：“哦，我们知道你会是种族主义者，当然，
because you're an American. But if you continue with this, we will beat you up. So what about Lincoln? I mean, is he not seen as a representative American? Of course he is. But don't forget, I mean, the British would have said, well, the Americans shot Lincoln. That's right.
因为你是美国人。但如果你继续这样下去，我们会揍你的。”那么林肯呢？我的意思是，他难道不被视为一个具有代表性的美国人吗？他当然是。但别忘了，我的意思是，英国人会说，好吧，美国人枪杀了林肯。没错。
Yes, that's right. So anyway, these black GIs arrive. Now, the United States at this point has a segregated army. So the Roosevelt government, the Roosevelt administration, writes formally to insist that Britain will uphold the segregation of the U.S. Army. And letters are sent out to local police and so on all across Britain to say, listen, these Americans are going to be segregated. We must do our best to uphold that. However, the British say, we will not segregate outside bases. In other words, we will not give you
是的，没错。所以无论如何，这些黑人美国大兵抵达了。现在，当时的美国有一支实行种族隔离的军队。因此，罗斯福政府、罗斯福行政当局正式致函坚持认为英国将维护美军的种族隔离。信件被发送给整个英国的当地警察局等等，上面写着，听着，这些美国人将实行种族隔离。我们必须尽最大努力维护这一点。然而，英国人说，我们不会在基地外部实行种族隔离。换句话说，我们不会给你
segregated pubs, segregated restaurants, all of these kinds of things. That's just not how we do things. It's too complicated, but it's also kind of not us. So what do the Americans do? The Americans say, well, black and white troops must stay separate, but they must also go out separately so they won't have to mix when they go out into the towns and villages of Britain. Tom, you were clearly itching to say something, and I'm wondering what it was. Well, I was just wondering about trains. So when they travel on trains, do they travel separately? And the reason- Yeah, I'm sure they would travel separately. So the reason I asked that is you may remember we did in the 12 Days of Christmas episodes we did
提供隔离的酒吧、隔离的餐厅以及所有这些种族隔离的场所。我们不习惯这么做。这太复杂了，而且这也不是我们的作风。那美国人怎么办？美国人说，好吧，黑人和白人士兵必须分开，但他们也必须分开外出，这样当他们去英国的城镇和村庄时，就不必混在一起了。汤姆，你显然急于说点什么，我想知道你想说什么。嗯，我只是在想火车的事。所以当他们坐火车旅行时，他们是分开旅行的吗？原因——是的，我确信他们会分开旅行。所以我这样问的原因是，你可能还记得我们在今年年初制作的“圣诞节的12天”节目中，我做过关于夏威夷的一期，夏威夷的王储在去过英国后，正坐着火车穿过美国返回夏威夷。是的，我记得。一个列车员试图以他不是白人为由将他从车厢里赶走，对此他愤怒地回答说：在英格兰，一个非洲人可以支付他的车票并坐在维多利亚女王旁边。好吧，汤姆，他没有错，因为英国没有隔离的火车。我的意思是，根本没有足够大的非白人人口来让这成为一个问题。现在，有趣的是，尽管你可能会对帝国的偏见之类的事情有所假设，但所有的证据都表明，大多数英国人都对白人美国士兵对待黑人战友的态度感到由衷的震惊和惊讶。
at the beginning of the year, I did one on Hawaii and the Crown Prince of Hawaii was traveling back to Hawaii across America on a train, having been to Britain. Yes, I remember that. And a conductor tries to remove him from his compartment on the grounds that he's not white, to which he indignantly replies, in England, an African can pay his fare and sit alongside Queen Victoria. Right. Well, he's not wrong, Tom, because there aren't segregated trains in Britain. I mean, there simply isn't a large enough non-white population for this even to be an issue. Now, the interesting thing is that despite what you might assume about imperial prejudices and whatnot, all the evidence is that most Britons are genuinely shocked and surprised by the attitude of white American soldiers to their black comrades.
所以你看“大众观察”（Mass Observation），这是当时针对大众态度进行的一项伟大调查。你看人们的信件和日记。事实上，你看黑人美国人自己是怎么说的。因此，这是黑人记者罗伊·奥特利（Roy Otley）在《黑人文摘》（Negro Digest）杂志上写的一篇文章。他写道：这里的人们有一种种族宽容，这给了他们一个社会筹码。他们倾向于根据一个人的个人价值来接受他。因此，黑人在许多方面不仅仅是在理论上在这里享有社会平等。用黑人士兵的话来说，
So you look at mass observation, which was this great survey that was being done at the time about popular attitudes. You look at people's letters and diaries. Indeed, you look at what black Americans said themselves. So this is the black journalist Roy Otley writing in the journal Negro Digest. He wrote, the people here have a racial tolerance which gives them a social lever. They're inclined to accept a man for his personal worth. Thus, the Negro has social equality here in more ways than theory. To put it in the language of the Negro soldier,
我受到的待遇让我直到照镜子才知道自己是有色人种。现在，奥特利接着说，这并不是说英国民众中不存在某种程度的种族偏见。而是说这种偏见更加无意识，并且更多地与帝国联系在一起，而不仅仅是基于肤色。黑人美国人的庇护所通常是酒吧，所以他们会去酒吧。他们和白人同僚享有不同的假期，所以他们被允许外出到酒吧，而且一般来说，我认为公平地说，他们和当地人相处得很好。
I am treated so a man don't know he's coloured until he looks in the mirror. Now, Olly goes on to say, that's not to say there aren't degrees of racial prejudice in the British population. It is that they are much more unconscious and are much more wrapped up with the empire than purely on skin color the place of sort of sanctuary for black black americans is often the pub so they will go to the pub they have separate leave days from their white counterparts so they are allowed out to the to the pubs and there generally i think it's fair to say they get on pretty well with the locals
所以酒吧会，我的意思是，英国大众对美国人、对白人美国人有很多怨恨，但实际上很多人对黑人美国人感到相当同情。所以酒吧里会有这样的标语，例如，此地仅限英国人和美国黑人士兵使用，
so pubs will, I mean, there's a lot of resentment of Americans, of white Americans among the British population at large, but actually lots of people feel quite sorry for the black Americans. So pubs will have signs that say, for instance, this place is for the exclusive use of Englishmen and American Negro soldiers,
白人美国军官对此深感愤慨。所以在普雷斯顿附近的班伯布里奇（Bamber Bridge），一名白人美国军官写信回家说，我在这里注意到的一件事是我不喜欢的事实，那就是英国人不划定任何肤色界限。英国人一定很无知。我无法想象一个白人女孩怎么会跟一个黑人交往。现在，班伯布里奇很有趣，因为这是最终演变成公开暴力的两三个地方之一。我是指枪声，汤姆。枪声。
which obviously white American officers deeply resent. So in a place called Bamber Bridge near Preston, a white American officer writes home and says, one thing I noticed here and which I don't like is the fact that the English don't draw any color line. The English must be pretty ignorant. I cannot see how a white girl could associate with a Negro. Now, Bamber Bridge is interesting because it's one of two or three places where this ends in open violence. I mean in gunfire, Tom. Gunfire.
所以时间是 1943 年 6 月，在普雷斯顿附近的班伯布里奇。美国第八军，这是一支美国第八军的卡车连。你知道我们有多喜欢在这个播客中进行军事对话。所以这是一支美国第八军的黑人连队。你知道我们有多喜欢在这个播客中进行军事卡车对话。所以这是一支由白人军官率领的黑人连队。因《发条橙》而闻名的作家安东尼·伯吉斯（Anthony Burgess）在此期间也身在班伯布里奇。那么他当时多大？所以他当时相当年轻。
So we're in June 1943 in Bamber Bridge near Preston. The U.S. 8th, it's a truck company of the U.S. 8th Army. You know how we love military conversations on this podcast. So it's a black company of the US Eighth Army. You know how we love military truck conversations on this podcast. So it's a black company with white officers. The author, Anthony Burgess, famous for A Clockwork Orange, is also in Bamber Bridge during this period. So how old is he? So he's pretty young then.
我的意思是，他一定是个十几岁的孩子，诸如此类。我的意思是，因为他……所以他没有服兵役。他没有参战。不，不，不。他后来回忆说，美国白人军官要求酒吧建立颜色隔离栏，而
I mean, he must be a child in his teens, something like that. I mean, because he's... So he's not serving. He's not in the war. No, no, no. He remembers later that the US, the white officers demanded that the pubs institute a colour bar and the
班伯布里奇的房东们聚在一起，在酒吧里挂出了写着“仅限黑人士兵”的标语。这显然让他们极大地赢得了美国军官的喜爱。在 6 月 24 日和 25 日的晚上，黑人士兵和白人军官之间的打斗基本上演变成了一场枪战。
landlords of Bamber Bridge got together and put up signs that read Black Troops Only in the pubs. So that obviously endeared them enormously to the American officers. And on the night of the 24th and 25th of June, a fighting between black troops and white officers basically ends up in a shootout.
所以起初是一场拳击赛。人们回营地拿枪。他们开始在街上开枪。一名二等兵威廉·克罗斯兰（William Crossland）背部中弹身亡。另外四名黑人美国大兵受伤。这个消息传开了。更多的黑人美国大兵去营地的军火库拿了步枪，他们都带着步枪来到了镇上。
So there's a fistfight at first. People go back to get guns from the camp. They start shooting in the streets. One private, William Crossland, is shot in the back and killed. Four other black GIs are wounded. News of this spreads. More black GIs go and get rifles from the weapons store at the camp, and they all sort of arrive in the town with their rifles.
美国宪兵在一辆车上架设了一挺机枪，开着这挺机枪驶入班伯布里奇市中心。有很多枪击事件。设置了路障。冲突最终被平息。27 名黑人美国大兵被定罪并被判处劳役。回美国去。回美国去。
The U.S. military police put a machine gun on a vehicle and drive into the center of Bamber Bridge with this machine gun. There's a lot of shooting. There's barricades erected. It's eventually quelled. 27 of the black GIs are convicted and sentenced to hard labor. Back in America. Back in America.
我是说，说到长刑期，汤姆，长达几十年。他们服刑多久？好吧，这就是有趣的地方。大体上，这些事情都被压下来了。它们是在不公开的法庭上审理的，判决书、判决的细节都被保密了。所以实际上，谁写了一本名为《美国起义》（An American Uprising）的书？所以这里是一支为诺曼底登陆做准备的军械弹药连。类似的故事，在酒吧里打架，与白人士兵关系紧张，有人开枪。人们开着吉普车冲进康沃尔这个小镇的中心开枪，
I mean, talking long sentences, Tom, decades. How long do they serve? Well, this is the interesting thing. By and large, these things were hushed up. They were in closed court, and the sentences, the details of the sentences were kept secret. So actually, who's written a book called An American Uprising. So here it's an ordnance ammunition company training for D-Day. Similar story, fighting in the pub, tension with white soldiers, shots fired. People are riding into the center of this small town in Cornwall in Jeeps, kind of firing their guns.
当地人说这，呃，这就像狂野西部一样，最后，呃，这次有 14 名黑人士兵在佩恩顿因哗变受审，事情的运作方式基本上是美国人接管一个法庭，他们会挂起一面巨大的星条旗，这算是向你的 1812 年战争致敬，汤姆，他们会演奏国歌，美国的国歌，然后他们有点像，你知道，这是在英国法庭上的一场完全的美国式表演，所以有人在大喊“反对”以及诸如此类的事情，但是判决结果再次被保密，14 名被告被判处长期劳役，并被遣返回
A local says it's uh it's like the wild west um and eventually um 14 this time 14 black soldiers are tried for mutiny in Paynton and the way this sort of works is basically the Americans will take over a courtroom they will put up a big star spangled banner little nod back to your 1812 war there Tom uh they will play the national anthem the u.s national anthem and they're sort of you know it's a it's a full american performance in a british courtroom so there's people shouting objection and all that kind of thing uh but the sentences once again they are kept secret the 14 accused men are sentenced to long long periods of hard labor back in the
美国，而且在康沃尔，人们真切地感觉到这是一种可怕的不公正，黑人士兵受到了非常非常糟糕的对待，这些骚动基本上是他们的军官的种族主义产物，因为黑人士兵在和白人女孩跳舞，因为英国女孩很高兴看到他们以及所有这些事情，
united states um and and there's a real sense actually in Cornwall that this is a terrible injustice, that the black soldiers have been very, very badly treated, that basically these disturbances are the product of racism on the part of their officers because the black soldiers are dancing with white girls, because the British girls are glad to see them and all this kind of thing,
而白人美国军官不喜欢这样。然后可能最著名的是一年后的布里斯托尔，1944 年。我的意思是，在这里，400 名黑人美国大兵于 7 月 15 日星期六上街狂欢。他们和白人英国女性在一起。一个美国白人军官拦住他们，基本上说，你们不能跟白人女性厮混。你们必须全部回基地。
and the white American officers don't like it. And then probably the most famous one is Bristol a year later, 1944. I mean, here, 400 black GIs had gone out on the town on Saturday, the 15th of July. They are with white British women. An American white officer stops them and basically says, you can't go around with white women. You all have to go back to base.
冲突爆发了。120 名武装美国宪兵赶到。有很多枪击事件。我的意思是，这太不可思议了，汤姆。宪兵弄来一堆公共汽车封锁了街道，并从这些公共汽车后面开枪。天哪。一名宪兵被刺伤。
Fighting starts. 120 armed US military policemen pitch up. There is lots of shooting. I mean, it's unbelievable, Tom. The military policemen get a load of buses and blockade the street and are firing from behind these buses. Blimey. One policeman is stabbed.
一名黑人士兵被枪杀。许多黑人士兵腿部中弹，因为他们瞄准的是你的腿以使你失去行动能力，而不是杀死你。他们理想情况下不想
A black soldier is shot dead. Lots of black soldiers shot in the legs because they would aim at your legs to disable you rather than to kill you. They don't ideally want
杀死自己人。情况完全一样。布里斯托尔实际上实行了数天的宵禁以制止战斗。但这并不全是厄运和阴霾，事实上，
to kill their own side. And it's the same story. Bristol was actually put under curfew for several days to stop the fighting. But it's not all doom and gloom, actually.
我觉得以一个积极的基调结束节目的这一部分会很nice。所以美国大兵被派往赫尔附近的科廷姆（Cottingham）。汤姆，有一个很棒的网站，叫做“赫尔及东约克郡的非洲人项目”（The Africans in Hull and East Yorkshire Project），这基本上就是我收集这部分讨论内容的地方。所以他们都被派往了科廷姆。在赫尔，当地人似乎真的把他们放在了心上。
I think it'd be nice to end this bit of the show on an upward note. So GIs are sent to Cottingham near Hull. There's a brilliant website, Tom, called the Africans in Hull and East Yorkshire Project, which is where basically I've sort of gleaned this bit of the discussion from. So they're all sent to Cottingham. And up in Hull, actually, the locals really seem to have taken them to their hearts.
所以有一点，一群非裔美国士兵去了威尔伯福斯纪念碑（Wilberforce Monument）。没错。因为威尔伯福斯当然是赫尔人。当时的报纸报道。解放奴隶、领导废除奴隶贸易的人。所以他是 19 世纪初英国的反奴隶制斗士。有报纸报道，当地报纸称，一群非裔美国人来到标志着赫尔威尔伯福斯纪念碑原址的牌匾前，他们跪下来亲吻地面。汤姆，你敢相信吗？
So there's a point at which a group of African-American soldiers go to the Wilberforce Monument. Right. Because Wilberforce, of course, is a Hull man. And the newspaper accounts of the time. The man who emancipates the slave, leads the abolition of the slave trade. So he's the sort of champion of anti-slavery in Britain at the turn of the 19th century. And there are newspaper accounts, local newspapers, that say that groups of African-Americans go to the plaque that marks the original site of Hull's Wilberforce Monument, and they kneel down and kiss the ground. Can you believe that, Tom?
天哪。但还有几个可爱的小故事。所以有一个故事是，在 1943 年 2 月，一群非裔美国士兵被点名了。他们的名字在报道中没有给出。他们去参加了一个疏散儿童派对，遇到了三个黑人孤儿，他们的父亲来自西印度群岛，在被U型潜艇袭击中丧生，他们的母亲在战前就去世了，所以他们现在成了孤儿。由于担心德国轰炸，他们被从赫尔市中心疏散到农村，这些非裔美国士兵收养了他们，并让他们作为他们部队的吉祥物。他们筹集了 160 英镑，在那个年代这是一笔巨款，
Goodness. But there's a couple of lovely stories. So there's one story that in February 1943, a group of African-American soldiers are named. Their names aren't given in the accounts. They go to an evacuee party, and they meet three black children who've been orphaned their father came from the west indies and had been torpedoed by u-boats their mother had died before the war so they're now orphans they've been evacuated from the center of hull to the countryside because of fears of german bombing and these african-american soldiers take them and adopt them as the mascots for their unit. And they raise 160 pounds, which is an awful lot of money in those days,
用于他们的衣服和他们未来的教育。这就是西蒙斯一大家子。这是一个可爱的故事。另一个可爱的故事，有一个叫威利·杨（Wiley Young）的人。真的，我们对他的了解不多。他们只是某种追踪记录，美国军人。他遇到一个叫埃伦·科尔（Ellen Cole）的女人。给我的印象是她的丈夫去打仗了或者类似的事情，因为她有两个小孩，
for their clothes and for their future education. So that's the Simmons family. It's a lovely story. And another lovely story, there's a guy called Wiley Young. It's really, we don't know much about him. They were just sort of trace records, American servicemen. He meets a woman called Ellen Cole. I get the impression that her husband was away at the war or something like this because she's got two small children,
但威利·杨和她成为了朋友，会在跳舞等活动后步行送她回家。他所在团的上校访问了埃伦·科尔的家，并要求她不要与黑人军人保持友好关系。她说：上校，你现在可不在美国。如果我想社交，我会的。这是我的家，事情就到此为止。而黑人军人威利·杨对这一点非常赞赏，他把自己的照片和她的孩子拍了下来。所以这张照片在这个网站上，孩子们打扮成山姆大叔和不列颠尼亚，所以他和这两个孩子在一起，他把照片寄回家的家人并说：你永远不会相信有一天，你知道，你的儿子会和白人英国家庭合影，这在家乡是绝对不可能发生的。而且，嗯，好吧，但为了……追踪另一个方面，因为它会引出我认为你接下来要谈论的内容。是的。那种性嫉妒的问题是一个相当明显的线索，对吧？哦，极度严重。然后美国大兵来到英国的故事，所以在当地被付予过高的薪水，过度性活跃。是的。英国男人倾向于说的话。
but Wiley Young becomes friends with her and will walk her home after dances and things. The colonel of his regiment visits Ellen Cole's house and asks her to refrain from being friendly with black servicemen. She says, Colonel, you're not in America now. If I want to socialize, I will. It's my home and that's the end of the matter and while young the black serviceman is very taken with this um he has his photo taken with her children so the photo is on this website uh the children dressed up as uncle sam and as britannia so he's with these two kids and he sends the photo home to his family and he says um you would never have believed that one day i would have you know your son would have his photo
因为许多英国妇女、妇女和女孩，呃，显然对美国人很好，你知道，他们有很多钱，他们的制服好得多，关于他们的牙齿有一些胡说八道，汤姆，所有这些乱七八糟的东西，而且我想，围绕着你刚才所说的关于黑人军人与白人英国女孩交往的焦虑的一部分，也表达了白人美国人对种族混血的焦虑。完全正确。这贯穿始终。我的意思是，他们是南方的白人士兵。你知道，他们看到这一幕惊呆了。他们只是认为这违背了自然和上帝的法则。但这确实表达了一种方式，不是吗，美国似乎，你知道，无论是对白人还是对英国人的黑人来说，似乎都更性感。确实如此。战争让英国，你知道，无论是对白人还是对英国人的黑人来说，似乎都更性感。确实如此。战争让英国，你知道，它有点褪色、灰暗，到处都是紧缩政策。而在美国，一切都是关于明亮的初级色彩。绝对正确。财富、速度。所以这种“美国很酷”的想法，可以说是这个词，在英国战后看待美国的方式中产生了巨大的影响。我认为你完全正确。而且我认为大约有 20 年的时间，
taken with a white british family could never happen at home and um yeah there you go well well but um just to uh pursue one further aspect because it will lead into, I think, what you're going to talk about next. Yeah. That issues of kind of sexual jealousy are quite a strand, aren't they? Oh, massive. And then the story of the American GIs coming to Britain, so overpaid, over-sexed over here. Yeah. What British men tend to say.
从这个时间点开始。正如我所说，他们于 1942 年抵达。所以我想大约有 22 年的时间，美国在不仅是高文化方面完全占据了上风。我的意思是，你想想，我不知道，抽象表现主义和索尔·贝娄（Saul Bellow）或类似的东西，还有流行文化。特别是在 20 世纪 50 年代和 60 年代初期，人们有一种真切的感觉，即英国正在变得彻底美国化。所以哈里·霍普金斯（Harry Hopkins）在 1964 年写了一本名为《新面貌》（The New Look）的书，回顾了 40 年代末、50 年代初。他说，美国的习俗和时尚现在正以一种暗示英国现在只是又一个离岸岛屿的速度和大同小异穿过大西洋。在约翰·奥斯本（John Osborne）1956 年的戏剧《愤怒的回头看》（Look Back in Anger）中，也就是苏伊士运河危机的那一年，主角吉米·波特（Jimmy Porter）说：我必须说，
Because a lot of British women women and girls um are obviously fine americans uh you know they've got lots of money they're very got much better uniform some nonsense about their teeth tom all that kind of stuff all that kind of stuff and i guess also that part of the anxieties around what you're saying about black servicemen yeah mixing with white british girls is expressive of white American anxieties about miscegenation. Absolutely right. It's kind of run through. I mean, they're Southern white soldiers. You know, they are stunned to see this. They just think it's against the laws of nature and God. But it's expressive of a way, isn't it, that America just seems, you know, whether it's white
生活在美国时代真是相当沉闷，当然，除非你是美国人。也许我们所有的孩子都会成为美国人。当然，此时的孩子、青少年，我的意思是，“青少年”（teenager）这个词本身就是一个美国发明。他们在模仿美国的时尚，特别是在听美国的音乐。所以 1956 年也是比尔·哈利和他的彗星乐队（Bill Haley & His Comets）来到英国并激发人们极大兴奋的一年。但是，尤其能激发利物浦（你知道的，随手抓的一个城市）人们灵感的音乐是黑人音乐。是的，没错。这就是黑人音乐。
or black to British people, just seems sexier. It does indeed. The war leaves Britain, you know, whether it's white or black to British people, just seems sexier. It does indeed. The war leaves Britain, you know, it's kind of washed out, grey, austerity everywhere. Whereas in America, it's all about bright primary colours. Absolutely right. Wealth, speed. And so that idea that America is, I guess, cool would be the word, is something that is hugely influential in the way that Britain comes to see America in the post-war years. And I think you're absolutely right. And I think there's about a 20-year period
所以这种音乐，所以它是，你知道的，蓝调和所有这些，但显然特别真实，不仅在像披头士乐队这样的组合中（你知道滚石乐队、所有这些家伙、东北部的动物乐队，所有这些乐队都受到黑人音乐的启发），而且音乐的交流是单向的。所以有几个人，呃，在英国对美国市场产生了奇怪的冲击，其中一个就是朗尼·多纳根（Lonnie Donegan），他……斯基菲尔音乐（Skiffle）。斯基菲尔音乐。但他唱歌时带有一种模仿的、带有鼻音的假美国口音。
after this point. So as I said, they arrived in 1942. So I'd say there's about a 22-year period when America completely has the upper hand in terms of not just high culture. I mean, you think of, I don't know, abstract expressionism and Saul Bellow or something, but also popular culture. And there's a real sense in the 1950s in particular, and the very early 1960s, that Britain is just becoming completely Americanized. So Harry Hopkins writes a book called The New Look in 1964, looking back to the late 40s, early 50s. And he says, American habits and vogues now cross the Atlantic with a speed and certainty that suggested that Britain was now merely one more offshore island. In John Osborne's play, Look Back in Anger, 1956, the year of the Suez Crisis, the main character, Jimmy Porter, says, I must say,
另一个是阿克·比尔克（Acker Bilk），他穿着像一个爱德华时代的乐队领队，但他演奏的是爵士乐，而且没有歌唱。所以他不是，你知道的，他的大热曲目是《岸上的陌生人》（Stranger on the Shore）。这实际上在 1962 年 5 月登上了美国排行榜的第一名。但你可能会因为不知道他是英国人而被原谅。当然，正如你刚才所说，有一个绝对的转折点，而这个转折点就是披头士乐队的访问。
it's pretty dreary living in the American age, unless you're American, of course. Perhaps all our children will be Americans. And of course, children, teenagers at this point, I mean, the very word teenager is an American invention. They're copying American fashions, particularly listening to American music. So 1956 is also the year of Bill Haley and the Comets coming to Britain and inspiring, you know, sort of people terribly excited. But the music that particularly inspires people in Liverpool, you know, to snatch a city at random is black music. Yes, that's right. It is black music.
现在，起初，大多数美国高管，所以我们说的是 1963 年，大多数美国唱片公司高管对披头士乐队非常非常怀疑。因此，甚至在 1963 年夏天之后，当披头士乐队在英国取得了巨大成功时，Capitol 唱片公司的高管们——Capitol 是那家唱片公司——起初并不想在大西洋彼岸发行他们的唱片。事实上，他们的老板杰伊·利文斯顿（Jay Livingston）告诉乔治·马丁：“我们认为披头士乐队在这个市场上不会有任何作为，”这是因为你所说的，英国被认为是一个灰色的、饱受轰炸的、老式的、粗花呢的、土气的、无趣的、不性感的、绝望地不酷的、老土的地方。是的，为什么英国音乐……但最终，我想因为他们看到了尖叫的现象、在英国的巨大销量，Capitol 的高管们同意了，“好吧，我们给他们一次机会。”
So the musical, so it's, you know, the blues and all that, but obviously particularly true, not just in groups like the Beatles, you know the Rolling Stones all those guys that the animals in the northeast all these bands are inspired by black music and the musical traffic is all one way so there are there are a couple of people um in Britain who make sort of weird dents in the American market so one of them is is Lonnie Donegan, who... Skiffle. Skiffle. But he sings with an adopted nasal fake American accent.
关于这个故事，人们经常忽略的一点是，我们在英国经常讲述披头士飞越重洋、出乎意料地征服美国以及所有这类事情的故事。这实际上并不是完全出乎意料的，因为 Capitol 的高管们一旦决定这么做，他们基本上就决定全力以赴了。他们全力以赴，并且真正地制造了大量的炒作。所以《我想握住你的手》（I Want to Hold Your Hand），披头士在美国的第一首单曲，是在节礼日（12月26日）发行的，他们确保了，你知道的，拷贝被发送给顺从的唱片骑师（DJ），基本上对当地广播电台施加了巨大的压力
The other is Acker Bilk, who dresses as a kind of Edwardian band leader, but he's playing kind of jazz and there's no singing. So he's not, you know, Stranger on the Shore is his great hit. That actually reaches number one in America in May 1962. But you could be forgiven for not knowing that he was British. Now, of course, as you've just said, there is an absolute turning point, and that turning point is the visit of the Beatles.
去播放它。一切都是刻意安排的。因此，甚至在披头士于 1964 年 2 月 7 日抵达纽约之前，Capitol 已经花费了 5 万美元——这比他们以往在任何其他艺术家身上花费的金额多出 10 倍——用于海报、徽章、贴纸以及所有这些东西来制造炒作。
Now, at first, most American executives, so we're talking about 1963, most American record company executives were very, very suspicious of the Beatles. So even after the summer of 1963, when the Beatles have had tremendous success in Britain, Capitals executives, the Capitals is the record company, they don't want to release them at first across the Atlantic. And in fact, their boss, Jay Livingston, tells George George Martin we don't think the Beatles will do anything in this market and this is because of what you say that Britain is perceived as grey bombed out old-fashioned tweedy dowdy boring unsexy you know terminally uncool yeah why would British music but eventually I suppose because they've seen the phenomenon of the screaming of the massive sales in Britain, capital's executives agree, okay, we'll give them a go.
他们向全美国的唱片骑师发送了四页的宣传册。他们基本上贿赂了一群人。所以你看到的迎接披头士的那群人，他们是被收买的。每个人都得到了一美元。这就像弗拉基米尔·普京风格的人群，汤姆。他们得到了一美元和一件免费的披头士 T 恤。所以当披头士到达那里时，有 5 个人说，哦，披头士翻着白眼想，你知道，如果他们对披头士采取修正主义态度，如果他们戳破这个气球，那就太好了。但有时这有点像你刚才谈论的，
And the one thing that people often miss about this story, so we in Britain tell the story a lot about the Beatles flying over, unexpectedly conquering America and all this sort of stuff. It's actually not really unexpected because capitalitals executives once they decided to do it they basically decided to go all in they go all in and they really really generate a lot of hype so the i want to hold your hand the beatles first single in america is released on boxing day 26th of december and they make sure that it's you know copies are sent to compliant disc jockeys that basically enormous amount of pressure is put on local radio stations
人们对这个故事经常忽视的一点是，我们在英国经常讲述披头士乐队飞过去、意外征服美国等等诸如此类的事情。其实这并不是真的出乎意料，因为Capitol唱片的高管们一旦决定这么做，他们基本上就决定全力以赴了，他们全力以赴，并且真正地制造了大量的炒作，所以《I Want to Hold Your Hand》作为披头士乐队在美国的第一首单曲，在节礼日（12月26日）发行，他们确保你知道，唱片副本被寄给了听话的唱片骑师，基本上对当地广播电台施加了巨大的压力
to play it. Everything is contrived. So even before the Beatles arrive in New York, which is the 7th of February, 1964, Capitol have spent $50,000, which is 10 times as much as they've ever spent on any other artist, on posters, on badges, on stickers, all this kind of thing to generate the hype.
来播放它。一切都是人为策划的。因此，甚至在披头士乐队于1964年2月7日抵达纽约之前，Capitol就已经花费了5万美元，这比他们在任何其他艺术家身上花费的资金多出10倍，用于海报、徽章、贴纸以及所有这类事情来制造炒作。
They have sent four-page brochures to disc jockeys across the United States. They have basically bribed a crowd. So that crowd that you see to greet the Beatles, they have been bribed. They have been given each a dollar. It's like a Vladimir Putin crowd, Tom. They've been given a dollar and a free Beatles t-shirt. So when the Beatles get there and there's 5, who say, oh, the Beatles rolling their eyes and thinking, you know, it'd be lovely if they were revisionist about the Beatles, if they punctured the balloon. But sometimes it's a bit like you're talking about,
他们向全美国的唱片骑师寄去了四页的宣传册。他们基本上收买了一群人。所以你在那里看到的迎接披头士乐队的人群，他们是被收买的。每个人都被给了一美元。就像弗拉基米尔·普京的人群一样，汤姆。他们每人得到了一美元和一件免费的披头士T恤。所以当披头士乐队到达那里时，有5个人说，哦，披头士乐队翻着白眼想着，你知道的，如果他们对披头士采取修正主义态度，如果他们戳破这个气球，那该多好。但有时这有点像你所谈论的
I don't know, it's a ludicrous comparison, Martin Luther or something. Sometimes you just have to say, listen, there's no getting away from the facts of history. Go on, Tom. But I mean, isn't the reason the Beatles succeed is that they are repackaging American culture to a degree? They are, of course. The Americans are sufficiently attuned to English culture that this fusion is something that America can immediately buy into. Agreed. Absolutely. They speak English. I mean, if they didn't speak English, this would not have happened. So their press conferences and so on are absolutely central to all this. I mean, Beatles are foes who roll their eyes when i say their native wit and whimsy but um but their native wit as it were is an absolutely crucial part of the
我不知道，这真是一个荒谬的比喻，把披头士比作马丁·路德之流。有时你不得不说，听着，历史事实是无法回避的。说下去，汤姆。但我的意思是，披头士之所以成功，很大程度上不正是因为他们把美国文化重新包装了吗？当然是这样的。美国人对英国文化的接受度足够高，使得这种融合成为美国人能够立即接受的东西。完全同意。绝对是的。他们说英语。我的意思是，如果他们不会说英语，这一切都不会发生。因此，他们的记者招待会等环节绝对是这一切的核心。我的意思是，当我提到他们与生俱来的机智与奇思妙想时，有些人会翻白眼，但是嗯，但是他们与生俱来的机智可以说是整个
story but it's also the stereotype of it is that america is a nation in grieving after the assassination of kennedy and that it's this old world charm and life and light that revivifies it. I don't know whether, I mean, I'm sure you'll scoff at that. But the very fact that it is a myth that is told, I mean, it's a story that is told, it's a pretty radical reconfiguring of the role of Britain as being the country of light and joy and fizz and bubble. It's a massive reconfiguring.
故事中绝对至关重要的一部分，但关于它的刻板印象也是：美国是一个在肯尼迪遇刺后陷入悲痛的国家，正是这种旧世界的魅力、生活和光明让它重新焕发了生机。我不知道——我的意思是，我确信你会对此嗤之以鼻。但作为一个被讲述的神话，或者说一个被讲述的故事，它实际上是对英国作为一个充满光明、快乐、活力和生机的国家的角色的一次相当激进的重新建构。这是一次巨大的重新建构。
Now, I personally don't think it's so much the Kennedy assassination, so much as the fact that American rock and roll music had gone into a bit of a trough and that they don't really – no new trendsetters emerged. Elvis is slightly yesterday's man. The new trends of the mid-60s haven't really got going. There's a slight sort of sense of American pop music being a bit kind of moribund, popular culture being a tiny bit moribund, and the Beatles offer something new. And their sort of jokiness, their sense of irony, their willingness to poke fun at themselves, all of which are very much part of British popular culture, kind of musical culture. Nobody has really done anything like that in the American kind of pop music world yet. So they appear on The Ed Sullivan Show,
现在，我个人认为，与其说是肯尼迪遇刺的影响，不如说是因为当时美国的摇滚乐陷入了一段低谷，而且他们并没有真正——没有涌现出什么新的潮流引领者。猫王已经稍微有点过气了。60年代中期的新潮流还没有真正兴起。美国流行音乐有那么点走向衰亡的感觉，大众文化也有那么一点走向衰亡，而披头士带来了一些新东西。他们那种开玩笑的方式、幽默感、自嘲的意愿——所有这些都非常符合英国大众文化，或者说英国的音乐文化。在美国的流行音乐界，当时还没有人真正做过类似的事情。所以当他们出现在《埃德·萨利安秀》上时，
the biggest TV audience in American history, 73 million people, even Billy Graham, who never watches TV on the Sabbath. He watches it so that he can see what his daughters are getting so excited about, apparently. Then tremendous kind of chart success.
创造了美国电视史上最大规模的观众收视纪录，达到了7300万人，甚至连从未在安息日看电视的比利·格雷厄姆也看了。据说他看这个节目是为了看看他的女儿们到底在为什么这么兴奋。随后便取得了惊人的排行榜成功。
So that spring, the Beatles have places 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 31, 41, 46, 58, 65, 68, and 79 in the Billboard chart. So Taylor Swift-style dominance, I think it's fair to say. And that actually – so it's not just the Beatles, as you say, because otherwise it wouldn't be an interesting story. It's a story about the complete transformation of Britain's image so in the years before the Beatles arrival only Ackerbilk and the Tornado another instrumental the Tornado's Telstar had ever topped the Billboard chart but from February 1964 for the next two years British acts hogged the top spot in one out of every two
所以在那个春天，披头士在公告牌排行榜上占据了第1、2、3、4、5、31、41、46、58、65、68和79位。所以，我觉得可以说这是一种泰勒·斯威夫特式的统治力。事实上——所以这不仅仅是因为披头士，正如你所说，否则这就不会是一个有趣的故事了。这是一个关于英国形象彻底转变的故事，因为在披头士到来之前的几年里，只有阿克尔·比尔克（Acker Bilk）以及另一首器乐作品——“旋风”乐队（The Tornados）的《特尔斯塔》（Telstar）登上过公告牌排行榜的榜首，但从1964年2月开始的接下来两年里，英国艺人在每两周的榜单中就独占鳌头一次。
weeks. That's an incredible, from a country that previously had not done anything at all. But also, I mean, the explosion of music in the 60s, it's not just about the British conquering America. It's about British and American influences merging and mixing. Agreed. And so Bob Dylan, Jimi Hendrix come to Britain. Yeah, yeah. And it's the sense that there is maybe a kind of common Anglo-American culture once again. And that's the other, I mean, the other great British cultural artefact of the 60s, which is James Bond.
这真是不可思议，对于一个之前毫无建树的国家来说。但同时，我的意思是，60年代音乐的爆发，不仅仅是关于英国征服美国。这是英国和美国影响的融合与交织。完全同意。所以鲍勃·迪伦、吉米·亨德里克斯来到了英国。对，对。这就给人一种感觉：也许美英之间再次存在某种共同的文化。这就是另一个——我的意思是，60年代另一个伟大的英国文化产物，那就是詹姆斯·邦德。
I mean, that's all, that's the same thing, right? It's produced by Harry Saltzman and Albert R. Broccoli, who are Americans. The films are made with American money. They're made predominantly for the American market, but they are selling the idea of British cool. Now, the interesting thing about this is I do not think this could have happened before this point because of the empire, because we talked about that sense of admiration and resentment. I think you can only do all this once the resentment no longer exists. So, in other words, Britain is no longer the imperial bully actually what britain is now is the post-imperial jester poking fun at its own yes but also it it couldn't happen if the
我的意思是，这完全是、这就是同一回事，对吧？它是由哈里·萨尔茨曼和阿尔伯特·R·布洛科利制作的，他们都是美国人。这些电影是用美国的资金制作的。它们主要是为美国市场制作的，但它们兜售的是“英国酷”（British cool）的理念。现在，这里有趣的地方在于，我认为在这一点之前这本是不可能发生的，因为当时还有帝国存在，因为我们谈论过那种钦佩与怨恨并存的情绪。我认为只有当这种怨恨不复存在时，你才能做到这一切。换句话说，英国不再是那个横行霸道的帝国霸凌者，事实上，现在的英国是一个后帝国的弄臣，既在嘲弄自己——是的，但也同时，如果披头士
beatles had say been upper class or indeed um sean connery right yeah i mean that's true yeah that that obviously people in britain are, very attuned to the class system. Americans much less so. The divisions in America tend to be racial. In Britain, they tend to be class-based. But there is a sense that these are not the monocle-wearing redcoats who burn the villages of freedom-loving Americans. Exactly. I think that's absolutely right.
比如说出身于上流社会，或者甚至是肖恩·康纳利，这一切就不会发生，对吧？对，我的意思是，确实如此，对，英国人显然对阶级制度非常敏感。美国人则要迟钝得多。美国的阶级划分往往是基于种族的。而在英国，它们往往是基于阶级的。但人们有一种感觉，这些人并不是那些烧毁热爱自由的美国人村庄的、戴着单片眼镜的红衫军。完全正确。我认为完全是这样。
These are cheeky chappies. These are cheeky chappies. They're cheeky chappies. They're ordinary people. It's slightly hard to place them within an American context, which makes them kind of fun, makes them outsiders. So you have this British invasion. So this lasts, I would say, until about, let's say, the end of 1966. That's when you get the change to California,
这些是厚脸皮的小伙子。这些是厚脸皮的小伙子。他们是厚脸皮的小伙子。他们是普通人。要把他们归入美国的语境中有点困难，这让他们显得很有趣，让他们成为了局外人。所以你们迎来了这场“英国入侵”。因此，这段时期，依我来看，一直持续到大约，比方说1966年底。那时风向转向了加利福尼亚，
to the music of San francisco more folky more hippie-ish more political and you can actually just trace that statistically by looking at the charts and see how all these bands like the dave clark five and herman's hermits kind of fall out of fashion at about that point though the beatles and stones continued the beatles and stones continue but i think it's fair to say that britness loses some of its cool. So that sort of, you know, I'm wearing a pair of Union Jack knickers. I'm Austin Powers. That sort of sense, definitely. But you still get...
转向了旧金山的音乐——更加民谣化、更加嬉皮士风、更加政治化。你实际上可以通过查看排行榜的统计数据来追踪这一点，看到像戴夫·克拉克五人组（The Dave Clark Five）和赫尔曼的寄居蟹（Herman's Hermits）这样的乐队如何在那个时间点左右逐渐过时，尽管披头士和滚石乐队还在继续——披头士和滚石乐队确实在继续，但我认为可以说“英伦风”确实失去了一些酷感。所以那种，你知道的，我穿着印有英国国旗图案的内裤，我是奥斯汀·鲍尔斯。那种感觉，确实如此。但你仍然会……
So the, I mean, the archetypal parody of a rock documentary is Spinal Tap, where it's Americans pretending to be British. But the British aren't cool in Spinal Tap, are they? They're ludicrous. They're ridiculous. Yeah, they are ludicrous, but they're still the archetype of a successful rock band. They are, but I think the fact...
所以，我的意思是，摇滚纪录片的典型讽刺之作就是《摇滚万岁》（Spinal Tap），那是美国人在假装成英国人。但在《摇滚万岁》里英国人可不酷，不是吗？他们很荒谬。他们很滑稽。是的，他们确实很荒谬，但他们仍然是成功摇滚乐队的典范。是的，但我觉得事实是……
You wouldn't have made that in 1965, I would say. No, okay. Now, Spinal Tap actually is a nice segue because it illustrates... I mean, there's sort of... The sense of the British is becoming a bit ridiculous. That's always simmering, I think, even despite – I mean, it goes quiet during the British invasion,
你在1965年是拍不出这种作品的，我觉得。好吧。现在，《摇滚万岁》其实是一个很好的过渡，因为它说明了……我的意思是，有一种……英国人开始变得有点滑稽的感觉。我认为这种情绪一直都在暗中滋生，哪怕——我的意思是，在“英国入侵”期间它沉寂了下去，
but it's always there. You talked about Anglophobia. There's always, I think, a tendency, a pleasure, that some Americans get in sort of stamping on Britain. Dare I mention the Grey Lady, the New York Times. Now, that said, a lot of Americans do love Britain and they are coming over in increasing numbers. And I think what you get at the end of the 70s
但它一直都在。你谈到了仇英情绪。我认为，有些美国人在踩踏英国时总是有一种倾向，甚至能从中获得某种乐趣。我敢提那份“灰姑娘”报纸——《纽约话报》（New York Times）。话虽如此，许多美国人确实热爱英国，而且他们正以越来越快的数量涌入。我认为你在70年代末所看到的，
is a lovely example of those two things colliding. So this is my final vignette. It's the 5th of March, 1979. So it's only weeks after the end of the winter of discontent in Britain, this very gloomy, dreary period of terrible industrial unrest that is about to bring the end of James Callaghan's Labour government and usher in Margaret Thatcher. You've got a couple of classic American visitors to Britain. They're called Mr. and Mrs. Hamilton. She's born in Britain. He's from California.
就是这两种东西碰撞的一个极好的例子。所以这是我的最后一个小片段。那是1979年3月5日。因此，这仅仅发生在英国“不满的冬天”结束几周后——这是一个非常阴暗、沉闷、工业动荡可怕的时期，它即将终结詹姆斯·卡拉汉的工党政府，并迎来玛格丽特·撒切尔。你有一对去英国的典型美国游客。他们叫汉密尔顿先生和太太。她在英国出生。他来自加利福尼亚。
They've flown in. They drive up the m5 they arrive at their hotel which is in the english riviera tom you know the english riviera talky yeah yeah uh mr hamilton's in a foul mood he says everything's on the wrong side of the road what do you get for living in a climate like this that he thinks the m5 is like a back road because it's terrible he'd think the english riviera poor climate only a californian could think but finally they've arrived at that hotel like so many you know large numbers of tourists were coming 13 million tourists a year were coming to britain at the end of the 70s and a large proportion of them american mr hamilton is looking forward to getting a drink but
他们坐飞机抵达，沿着M5高速公路驱车前行，来到了他们在英国里维埃拉的酒店。汤姆，你知道英国里维埃拉的托基吧？对，对，嗯……汉密尔顿先生心情极坏，他说什么东西都在路的错误一侧。你怎么会住在这种气候里？他觉得M5高速公路就像一条乡间小路，因为太糟糕了。他觉得英国里维埃拉气候糟糕——只有加州人会这么想。但最终他们还是到达了那家酒店，就像许多——你知道的，有大量的游客正涌入，70年代末每年有1300万游客来到英国，其中很大一部分是美国人。汉密尔顿先生正盼望着能喝上一杯，但是
you know and then something to eat but the hotel owner says the kitchen's closed you know the kitchen stops at nine and uh would you have a ham or cheese sandwich instead and mr hamilton can't believe his ears and he says what the hell is wrong with this country you can't get a drink after three you can't eat after nine is the war still on and eventually there's a whole series of shambles it's mr hamilton orders um a waldorf salad he says I really want a Waldorf salad. And the hotelier says, I'm sorry, we're just out of Waldorfs. Because he doesn't know what a Waldorf salad is.
你知道的，还有吃点东西，但酒店老板说厨房已经关了，你知道的，厨房九点就停止营业了，嗯，你要不要换成火腿或乳酪三明治？汉密尔顿先生简直不敢相信自己的耳朵，他说这国家到底怎么了？三点以后喝不到酒，九点以后没东西吃，战争还在继续吗？最后发生了一连串的混乱，汉密尔顿先生点了一份——呃，华尔道夫沙拉，他说我真的很想吃一份华尔道夫沙拉。酒店老板说，很抱歉，我们刚好没有华尔道夫沙拉了。因为他根本不知道什么是华尔道夫沙拉。
Mr. Hamilton goes, what the hell is going on here? You know something, fella? If this was back in the States, I wouldn't board my dog here. And the hotelier says, fussy, you see? Poodle. And this is, of course, the episode Waldorf Salad from the sitcom Fawlty Towers, John Cleese sitcom.
汉密尔顿先生说，这到底是怎么回事？你知道吗，老兄？如果这在美利坚，我连我的狗都不会寄养在这里。酒店老板说，真挑剔，是吧？像个贵宾犬。这当然就是情景喜剧《金氏酒店》（Fawlty Towers）——约翰·克利斯的情景喜剧中《华尔道夫沙拉》那一集。
And if you haven't seen it, I heartily recommend it. It's very, very funny about Anglo-American cultural differences at the end of the 1970s. But actually, the brilliant thing about this is that it completely represents what people were saying about Britain. Americans were saying about Britain at the end of the 1970s, the beginning of the 1980s. I had a look at all these guidebooks about what American guidebooks said about Britain, because at this point, more Americans, I mean, apart from the war, more Americans are coming to Britain than ever before. So the Let's Go guide starts, I mean, the introduction, the Let's Go is done for backpackers and stuff. It's introduction, it says.
如果你还没看过，我强烈推荐。它非常非常有趣地展现了20世纪70年代末英美之间的文化差异。但实际上，这个桥段最精彩的地方在于，它完全代表了当时人们对英国的看法。美国人在20世纪70年代末、1980年代初就是这样评价英国的。我查阅了所有这些旅游指南，看看美国的旅游指南对英国是怎么说的，因为在此时，除了战争时期之外，有比以往更多的美国人来到英国。所以《Let's Go》指南的开头——我的意思是，《Let's Go》的引言是为背包客之类的人写的。它的引言写道：
Consider what happens to a country when quite unexpectedly for 20 years, everything goes wrong. Rapid economic decline, massive loss of prestige in world politics, unemployment, inflation, Northern Ireland, riots, such as Britain's position today. I mean, imagine, that's the introduction to a tourist guide. The Fodor's introduction, right, which is written for older, more affluent travellers. Again, this is 1982.
想象一下，当一个国家在完全意想不到的情况下，有20年时间诸事不顺，会发生什么。经济急剧下滑、世界政治中的声望大幅丧失、失业、通货膨胀、北爱尔兰问题、骚乱——这就是英国今天的处境。我的意思是，想象一下，这是一份旅游指南的引言。而《福多尔指南》（Fodor's）的引言也是如此，它专为年长、更富裕的旅行者而写。同样，这是1982年。
This is literally how the preface begins, Tom. For all its increasing air of shabbiness, its strikes, its unpredictable weather, Britain is still a desirable destination. So it's sort of, it's like you apologising for doing football in a Restless History podcast.
前言literally就是这样开头的，汤姆。尽管英国日益显露出破败感、罢工不断、天气变化无常，但它仍然是一个令人向往的目的地。所以这有点像——这就像你在《不安的历史》（Restless History）播客里谈论足球时还要道歉一样。
Yes, it is. So the guidebooks are hilarious. They go on and on about how terrible everything is. The thing that everyone goes on about, funny enough, going back to the faulty towers of the hotels. Paul Theroux, the great travel writer, wrote a book called Kingdom by the Sea in 1982. He's writing that during the Falklands War, isn't he?
是的，确实如此。所以这些旅游指南太荒谬了。它们喋喋不休地抱怨所有事情有多么糟糕。有趣的是，每个人都在喋喋不休地谈论酒店，这又回到了《金氏酒店》的话题。伟大的旅行作家保罗·索鲁（Paul Theroux）在1982年写了一本名为《海滨王国》（Kingdom by the Sea）的书。他是在马岛战争期间写这本书的，对吧？
Yeah. He says, every large hotel in Britain is run down or badly managed, overpriced, understaffed and dirty. The staff overworked and slow. He says the staff are always lazy, dishonest and aggressive. British hotels are indistinguishable from prisons or hospitals being run with the same indifference or cruelty. Which the British are aware of as well, because otherwise Fawlty Towers wouldn't have chimed the way they did. Of course.
对。他说，英国的每一家大型酒店都破旧不堪、管理不善、价格虚高、人手不足且肮脏不堪。员工过度劳累且行动迟缓。他说员工总是懒惰、不诚实且具有攻击性。英国的酒店与监狱或医院没有区别，都带着同样的冷漠或残酷在运营。英国人自己也是意识到了这一点的，否则《金氏酒店》就不会产生那样的共鸣了。当然。
So the British do kind of know this. But even so, I think people are still quite shocked by the way in which Americans talk about Britain because the way that Americans talk about British hotels is actually the way that Americans talk about Britain economically and politically. So 1975, very famously, the United States Secretary of State, Henry Kissinger, there's a transcript of an Oval Office White House conversation in which he says to Gerald Ford these words,
所以英国人其实是知道这一点的。即便如此，我认为人们仍然对美国人谈论英国的方式感到相当震惊，因为美国人谈论英国酒店的方式，实际上就是美国人从经济和政治角度谈论英国的方式。所以1975年，非常著名的是，美国国务卿亨利·基辛格，有一份椭圆形办公室白宫谈话的文字记录，他在其中对杰拉尔德·福特说了这样的话：
Britain is a tragedy, begging, borrowing, stealing until North Sea oil comes in, that Britain has become such a scrounger. It's a disgrace. Ford, when he leaves office in January 1977, I mean, this is so humiliating, Tom. In his farewell remarks as president, he says these words, it would be tragic for this country
英国是个悲剧，靠乞讨、借贷、偷窃度日，直到北海石油开采进来，英国已经变成了一个彻头彻尾的寄生虫。这太耻辱了。福特在1977年1月卸任时——我的意思是，这太羞辱人了，汤姆。在他作为总统的告别演讲中，他说出了这样的话：如果这个国家走上同样的道路，最终落得和英国一样的问题，那将是一场悲剧。
if we went down the same path and ended up with the same problems that Great Britain has. And this sort of goes on and on. There's a Harvard political scientist called Samuel Beer, writes a book in 1982 called Britain Against Itself. And in the preface, he explains why he's written the book. And he says, basically, I was inspired by a conversation with one of my students at Harvard. When Beer said to her, why do you want to do my class? She said, well, my father told me to do it. He said, study England, a country on its knees.
这种论调没完没了。有一位名叫塞缪尔·比尔（Samuel Beer）的哈佛政治学家在1982年写了一本书，名为《对抗自身的英国》（Britain Against Itself）。他在序言中解释了自己为什么要写这本书。他说，基本上，我是受到与哈佛一名学生的对话的启发。当比尔问她为什么要选修我的课时，她说，哦，我父亲让我选的。他说，去研究一下英国吧，一个跪倒在地的国家。
That's where America is going. And that view is, I mean, it's so widespread. Well, so this is going back to the Harold Macmillan, Greece and Rome. It is, absolutely. And the people that absolutely incarnate this. So this is what brings it back to the present. The institution that is the embodiment of this attitude is the New York Times. So then as now, I mean, you could swap New York Times articles about post-Brexit Britain
美国就要走向那里。这种观点——我的意思是，它是如此普遍。好吧，这又回到了哈罗德·麦克米伦的希腊与罗马论。确实如此，完全是这样。而绝对将这一点体现得淋漓尽致的人——所以这又把话题拉回了现在。体现这种态度的机构就是《纽约时报》。因此，无论过去还是现在，我的意思是，你可以把《纽约时报》关于后脱欧时代的英国的文章，
with New York Times articles about 1970s Britain. Unbelievable. But isn't it, I mean, today it's more complicated because I think we discussed this before, that it's a marketing strategy for the New York Times. Yes. Because it's looking to expand into the British market. And so it's pitching at people who are to the left of the Guardian. Right.
与《纽约时报》关于1970年代英国的文章互换。难以置信。但难道不是吗？我的意思是，如今情况更加复杂了，因为我想我们之前讨论过，这是《纽约时报》的一种营销策略。是的。因为它正寻求向英国市场扩张。所以它的目标受众是那些政治立场比《卫报》还要偏左的人。没错。
It's people who love the self-flagellation. But that's not what the New York Times is doing in the – I mean, when the New York Times writes in 1978 on – No, not in the 80s. It's an indisputable fact that Britain has a relatively low standard of living, a poor choice of goods, bungling and slowness at all levels, and a manana attitude that infuriates even spaniards i mean all this i mean i apologize to spanish listeners i mean even
这些人喜欢自我鞭笞。但这不是《纽约时报》在——我的意思是，当《纽约时报》在1978年写道——不，不是在80年代。这是一个无可争辩的事实：英国拥有相对较低的生活水平、糟糕的商品选择、各个层面上的笨拙与拖沓，以及一种连西班牙人都感到愤怒的“明天再说”（mañana）态度——我的意思是，所有这些——我的意思是，我向西班牙听众道歉——我的意思是，甚至
all this sort of stuff is not aimed at getting subscribers it speaks to some degree of maybe even unconscious contempt absolutely but but if we i mean if we look going forward now yeah i think there is a difference there, which is that actually, I mean, you were saying that in the years immediately after the war, there was an anxiety in Britain that Britain was basically becoming an American satrapy. And I think the fact that Britain is seen now by the American behemoths that govern the media, and particularly social media and the internet and all those kinds of things. I mean, it is simply a province now. I mean, it's simply a subdivision to be developed however you want to. And that's what the New York Times are doing.
所有这类言论都不是为了吸引订阅者，它在某种程度上甚至反映了一种潜意识中的蔑视。绝对是的。但是如果我们——我的意思是，如果我们把目光投向现在，是的，我认为这里有一个区别，那就是实际上，我的意思是，你刚才说在战后紧接着的几年里，英国有一种焦虑，担心英国基本上会变成美利坚的一个行省。我认为，现在英国被统治媒体、特别是社交媒体、互联网以及所有这些玩意的美国庞然大物所看待的事实——我的意思是，它现在简直就是一个行省。我的意思是，它仅仅是一个可以随心所欲进行开发的行政区划。这就是《纽约时报》在做的事情。
Tom, this is very depressing. But I think the consequence of that is that actually we are much more Americanized now than we've ever been because of social media. And because the language of the internet is American. Well, our intellectual elite are more Americanized than they've ever been. And they're the people, for example, who use media, academics. They're the people who are on Twitter and who are picking up American obsessions, who are getting excited about whether or not you can say Anglo-Saxon. Exactly. All of these kinds of things. But are of the public at large people who work in shoe shops i don't know i mean i know that's always your your argument i don't know that's the
汤姆，这太令人沮丧了。但我认为其结果是，由于社交媒体的存在，实际上我们现在比以往任何时候都更加美国化了。而且因为互联网的语言就是美式英语。嗯，我们的知识精英比以往任何时候都更加美国化了。他们正是那些使用媒体的人，比如学者。他们是那些泡在推特上、对是否能说“盎格鲁-撒克逊”这样的词大惊小怪的人。正是所有这些。但广大公众呢？那些在鞋店工作的人呢？我不知道——我知道这总是你的论点，我不知道，
sambrick reflex i think that is the sambrick reflex i guess they're all watching netflix i guess they're what you know yeah they're probably watching the bbc less they're watching netflix more i would say so we should end by saying how that Fawlty Towers thing ends. Because of course, I promised you this, Mr. Hamilton, and this is your thing about British self-flagellation,
这就是“萨姆布里克反射”（Sambrik reflex），我想这就是“萨姆布里克反射”。我猜他们都在看网飞（Netflix）。我猜他们——你知道的，是的，他们可能看BBC变少了，看网飞变多了，我会这么说。所以我们应该以讲述《金氏酒店》那一集是如何结束的来收尾。因为当然，我向你承诺过这个，汉密尔顿先生，这就是你刚才说的关于英国人自我鞭笞的话题，
Tom, because Mr. Hamilton assembles the other guests and Basil gives this fantastic speech. He says, they all satisfy customers. Of course, if this little hotel
汤姆，因为汉密尔顿先生把其他客人都召集了起来，然后巴斯尔发表了一段精彩绝伦的演讲。他说，他们都让顾客满意。当然，如果这家小小的酒店
is not to your taste, then you are free to say so. That is your privilege. And I shall, of course, refund your money. I know how important it is to you Americans, he says. But you must remember that here in Britain are things that we value more, things that perhaps in America you've rather forgotten, but which here in Britain are far, far more important.
不合您的口味，那么您大可以直言不讳。那是您的特权。我当然也会把钱退给您。我知道这对你们美国人有多重要，他说。但你们必须记住，在英国，有些东西是我们更为珍视的，有些东西也许你们在美国已经渐渐遗忘了，但在英国，这些东西要重要得多得多。
And at that point, somebody interrupts him and says, I'm not satisfied. And then all the other British guests say, yeah, it's actually terrible. And so the American wins the day. Do you know how Basil ends the entire conversation, Tom? I can't remember. This is exactly how Nazi Germany started. Well, that is the perfect note on which to end a history podcast.
就在那时，有人打断了他，说道：“我对这里很不满意。”然后所有其他的英国客人纷纷附和：“是的，这里确实糟糕透顶。”于是美国人赢得了胜利。你知道巴斯尔是怎么结束整场对话的吗，汤姆？我不记得了。纳粹德国就是这样开始的。好吧，这绝对是结束一个历史播客的完美音符。
We hope you have enjoyed it. May the best team today win. And we will see you again tomorrow for more I don't know where we're going because we haven't worked out more historical wittering more historical witterings we'll see you then
希望你们喜欢今天的节目。祝今天最好的一方获胜。我们明天还会再见，带来更多——我不知道我们要去向何方，因为我们还没想好更多的历史胡扯——更多的历史闲聊，我们到时候见。
bye bye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History for bonus episodes early, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
拜拜。感谢收听《不安的历史》。想要收听独家加更节目、提前收听无广告版并加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐即历史》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和八卦花絮。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertrainment.com。网址是 therestisentertrainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。